ALL OKAY SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND GET THIS HEARING
STARTED. ONE WISH EVERYONE A
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY-
DECEMBER AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY- THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE- THIS HERE'S AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON.
IMPATIENS NECROTIC SPOT VIRUS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS I. N. AS V.
AND- AND PYTHIUM WILT AND OTHER
LEAFY GREEN PLANT SOME DISEASES.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE WILL BE HERE SHORTLY A
COUPLE OF- MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE JOINING US. I
WANT TO THANK OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF VICTOR FRANKEL **** NICOLE
WILLIS AND BOTH OF OUR CAPITAL
IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICE STAFF FOR
ALL THE WORK- IN. PAIRING FOR
THIS HEARING I KNOW IT'S A
CHALLENGING TIME BVIOUSLY- AS
THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN
SESSION AND IT IS- YOU KNOW IN
THE MIDDLE OF A HALL OF OUR
HOLIDAY SEASON. SOME LOGISTICS
AND PROTOCOLS- HER TEARS SO DUE
TO THE CONTINUE TO COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS WE CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE AND- THIS- HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
FOR THOSE THAT ARE- HERE IN
ATTENDANCE THIS AFTERNOON BOTH
HEARING US SOME PARTICIPANTS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE
KNOW THAT. THE DROUGHT THIS
HEARING FACE COVERINGS ARE
REQUIRED AND ARE TO BE WORN AT
ALL TIMES IN FISCAL
DISINCENTIVES EXPECTED TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. IF YOU DON'T HAVE A FACE
COVERING ONE CAN BE PROVIDEDTO
YOU- THE PHONE NUMBER TO MAKE US
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE SHOWN OR
PROVIDED TO VIEWERS ON SCREEN.
AT THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING OF
THE PHONE NUMBERS ALSO POSTED ON
ARE SIMPLY- HI COMMITTEE WEBSITE
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IS ALSO
WELCOME TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
COMMENTS TO. OUR COMMITTEE EMAIL
THROUGH- AND EMAILS MAY BE SENT
TO THE ADDRESS FOUND ON OUR
WEBSITE WHICH IS A E. G. R. I.
DOT. COMMITTEE WHICH IS C. O. M.
M. I. T. T. S. ASSEMBLY THAT'S
A. S. S. E. M. B. L. Y. DOT CA
DOT GOP. AND SO- AGAIN THE
PURPOSE FOR THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. IS TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
FOR US TO LEARN ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF LEAFY GROUP GREEN
I'LL PLANT SOME DISEASES AND
SAFE GUARDED AGAINST
AGRICULTURAL SOME CATASTROPHE.
IT'S CRITICAL IT IS CRITICAL TO
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AS WELL AS
OUR OVERALL NATIONAL- SINCE OUR
NATIONAL- SOME SECURITY. AS WE
KNOW- HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
STATE. WE HAVE A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION AGRICULTURAL- A
POWERHOUSE. AND WE CULTIVATE AS
A STATE WE CULTIVATE ONE THIRD
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
VEGETABLES AND TWO THIRDS OF THE
NATION'S FRUITS AND NUTS.
HOWEVER IN RECENT YEARS
WILDFIRES DROUGHT PESTS. AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS GLOBAL OP
PANDEMIC CAN COVER NINETEEN.
THEY HAVE THREATENED OUR STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR AND- AND
JEOPARDIZING IN THE PROCESS OF
THE ENTIRE NATION'S FOOD SUPPLY
. AND FOOD SECURITY AND AS I'VE
LEARNED AS I'VE TOURED AND
VISITED AGRICULTURAL REGIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA EVERY REGION
FACES UNIQUE CHALLENGES UNIQUE
ISSUES AND IN THE CENTRAL REGION
OF THE SALINAS VALLEY A REGION
THAT I REPRESENT HERE IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY THE HEART OF
LEAFY GREEN ASSETS- SOME
PRODUCTION. TO SIGNIFICANT SOME
DISEASES ARE AFFECTING THAT
PRODUCTION- IMPATIENS. NECROTIC
SPOT VIRUS REFERRED TO AS I. N.
S. B. AND PYTHIUM WILL. I IN IS
V. IS CARRIED BY SOME TINY
INSECTS CALLED THRIPS WHICH ARE
SO SMALL THAT THEY'RE BARELY
EVEN VISIBLE BUT ARE CAUSING
CHAOS. IN GENERAL I AND IS TO
BE- IT CAUSES YELLOWING OF OLDER
LEAFS AND EXTENSIVE AND- US IN
THE CROCE'S OF- ON ON JUNGLE
LEAVES. BUT NO WILL TAKE. ON THE
OTHER HAND THE PIT THEM WILT
UNLIKE I. N. S. B. IS A DISEASE
AND NOT TRANSMITTED BY INSECT.
BUT RATHER IS BORN IN THE SOIL
AND- PRESUMABLY LEAVING BEHIND
PATHOGENS SACRAMENTO VIABLE AND
SOIL FOR YEARS. AND IT'S A PITY
HIM IS A BIT IT'S THIS ROOT ROT
INFECTING ROOTS WITH SWIMMING
SPORES MAKING AND TIRELESS
FILLED WILT AND EVENTUALLY- THEY
COLLAPSE. AND ALTHOUGH BOTH OF
THESE DISEASES HAVE BEEN AROUND
FOR YEARS LAST YEAR AND TWENTY
TWENTY THE RAPID ONSET OF SEVERE
DAMAGE FROM BOTH AYE IN THIS B.
AND PITY AND WEALTH RESULTED IN
ALIGNMENT IMPACTS AND CROP
LOSSES. AND WHAT'S CAUSING
MAJOR- SOME CONFUSION REGARDING
THE MAIN CAUSES OF- THIS CROP
DAMAGE AND PLANT LOS. IS I. N.
AS V. AND- THIS PITT TEAM WILL
OFTEN BUT NOT IN EVERY CASE OUR
CURRENT IN THE SAME FIELD. AND
AS I'VE OBSERVED FIRSTHAND IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY. THESE TWO-
THESE DISEASES ARE CAUSING A
PERFECT STORM OF DEVASTATION AND
PROBLEMS. AND WELL. THESE THESE-
THESE UP- THE PATHOGENS ARE ARE
ARE NOT HARMFUL TO HUMANS
FARMERS IN MONTEREY AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY IN OUR SURROUNDING
REGION. HAVE BEEN A HIT
INCREDIBLY HARD AND FOR A REGION
KNOWN AS A SELLABLE OF THE
WORLD- THAT- PRODUCES OVER ONE
BILLION AND LEAFY GREENS
ANNUALLY. THESE SHOCKINGLY
SUBSTANTIAL YIELD LOSSES HAVE
TRANSLATED TO SOME PERSONAL
ECONOMIC LOSSES JOB LOSSES AND A
REDUCTION IN OUR REGIONAL AND
STATE ECONOMIC OUTPUT. AND WHILE
THIS HEARING WILL NOT- PROVIDE
AN IMMEDIATE REMEDY IT WILL
HOPEFULLY OFFER A PLATFORM FOR
LEGISLATORS FOR FARMERS AND FOR
SCHOLARS TO WORK TOGETHER TO
HAVE A DIALOGUE IN THEIR EFFORT
TO LIMIT TO PREVENT A LEAFY
GREEN PLANT- SOME DISEASES SUCH
AS I. N. S. B. AND US PET HIM
WILT. AND HOPEFULLY- AS WE MOVE
INTO THE FUTURE WE COULD FIND-
THE APPROPRIATE REMEDY AND- SOME
. SOME SOME SOLUTIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS HEARING AND WITH
THAT WE WILL MOVE RIGHT INTO THE
FIRST PANEL- WHICH IS- TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE
OVERVIEW IMPACT OF THIS ISSUE.
AND THE FIRST PANELIST IS MERRY
ZINC WHO IS WITH THE GROWER
SHIPPER ASSOCIATION OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA MERRY ARE YOU WITH US. YEAH I'M HERE RADIOLOGY.
FANTASTIC REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
MAKING THE TIME FOR US AND FOR
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC AND SO IF
YOU'RE READY TO GO- PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO OFFER TESTIMONY. ALL.
WELL I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO-
BRING HOME WHAT YOU TOLD ALLEN
ARAMBULA CURRENTLY ALREADY
DESCRIBED BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE HERE IS LIKE NOTHING
THAT ANY OF US HAVE EVER SEEN
THE TOWARD AND WE- APPRECIATE
ALL THE HELP THAT IS BEING
OFFERED TO US REGARDING THIS
PROBLEM. SO REGARDING THIS
PHOTOGRAPH THAT YOU SEE ON MY
OPENING WHY I THINK MOST PEOPLE
EVER BEEN TO THE DISCIPLINE IS
BADLY WITH THINK ABOUT PHOTO ID
EITHER BEEN PHOTOSHOPPED TO MAKE
US LOOK BAD OR A REALLY DREADFUL
PROBLEM IN IS NAY SELF NOMINATE
UNFORTUNATELY BACK IF THE LATTER
WE HAD WE HAD AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER ON OUR HANDS LAST YEAR-
IN. THE FILLING IS VALID. WELL
MORE MARDI WHY. AT OKAY SO IN
REACT TO THE FACT THAT SOME
GROWERS WERE SO MANY- CHIU THAT
VIRUS- A MEETING WAS HELD LAST
SEPTEMBER IN SALINAS AND NEVER
OVER SEVENTY ATTENDEES PRIMARILY
GROWERS BUT ALSO SOME SHIPPERS
AND SOME PROCESSORS TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IS THERE ANY OTHER
THE OF THE NEEDS ON OUR CALL
LETTERS CRAP AND HE COULD YOU OF
THAT MEETING WAS THAT ATTACK
COURT NEED TO BE. YOU SEE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM. AND
THAT TIME AND HAVE OF LAST YEAR
. THE TASK FOR YOU NOT. PRETTY
MUCH EVERY WEEK. FOR ME. AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU IN OUR IN. YOU
PROBABLY KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
GROW HATE MOST IS NEED. AND
WEEKLY MEETING IN ORDER TO ON
THE BALLOT. REALLY TO ALLOW OF
THEM BUT WE GOT A CORE GROUP
PEOPLE. BOTH GROWERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY AND
PEOPLE FROM EXTENSION AND OTHER-
INDUSTRY PEOPLE WHO SERVICE. OUR
GROWERS- IT'S HARD TO FINANCE
MINISTER BAKER HAVE ALL BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THIS TASK FORCE
OVER THE- BACK HERE. AND ARE
FOCUS IS WE TO GO WAS TO. LOWER
INCIDENCE DISEASE IN THE TRI
TWENTY ONE. SO ONE OF THE FIRST
ACTION THAT WE- WANTED TO GET
THE OTHER STATE PLANT
PATHOLOGISTS JUNE ZERO FIVE WHAT
WE ALREADY KNEW BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE WERE ALL TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME THING. AND SO WE
SPENT A DAY WHERE HEATHER SHACK
FROM CDFA VISITING NINE
DIFFERENT RANCHES TO LOOK AT THE
DISEASE'S IMPACT AND FOR HER TO
DRIVE SAMPLES. AND IT GATHERED
CAMPUS NINE SAMPLES FROM NINE
RANCHES THEY WERE ALL POSITIVE
FOR THAT VIRUS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND IF HE SB SEVEN
OF THOSE SAME SAMPLES WERE ALSO
POSITIVE. FOR PYTHIUM. SO WE HAD
OUR DOCTOR MAYES DOT. IN FROM
STANDPOINT BUT THE THING WE
WANTED TO WITH TRY AND THE LAW
BECAUSE THAT WOULD REALLY BRING
. ALL OF THE OTHER THIS LINES WE
DID GROWER SURVEY WHICH IS THE
SAME GIRL ARE TAKING MORE THAN
ME. ARE YOU THAT WE GOT A PRETTY
GOOD WAY. WE'VE GOTTEN DETAILS
INFORMATION ON THIRTEEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DEALS THAT HAD NEEDED
SHEET AND AMONGST THOSE FIELDS
THE AVERAGE CRAP ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE PERCENT. WHICH I
THINK MOST OF YOU KNOW AND IT'S
JUST NOT A SUSTAINABLE NUMBER
GAVE. THE DEAL THAT. AND IN MOST
CASES THOSE FIELD HAD BOTH IRAN
AND. THE AND THE ON. SO TO BACK
THAT UP EVEN MORE OR TO. OUR
EVEN MORE WE CAN DO IN A- STUDY
. WITH TWELVE LARGE IF COULD DO
NOT A WHOLE VALLEY BUT A
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE. AND A MOM
. THE WHO PURCHASE. IN THE STUDY. WE ARE COMMITTED ARE- LAW AND
WE USUALLY FORTY AND MILLION
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR. THE OTHER THING THAT
WOULD BE MOST. ABOUT THAT
STARTED WITH THE FACT GROW RISK
A LOT MORE MONEY. CURRENTLY AND
HAS MADE. TO THE THREE. AND SO
WE THOUGHT INCREASE OF SIX
HUNDRED NINETY DOLLARS PER ACRE
ON AVERAGE TO DEAL WITH HAS
MANAGEMENT CAUGHT SO COMBINING
ME ATACAR AND THE LOSS IN
REVENUE WE BELIEVE THAT IMPACT
WITH MORE IN THE TERRITORY OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE BELIEVE
THAT COULD BE. A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE. OTHER ACTIONS THAT WE. EVERY BEGAN THE PROCESS WOULD
BE TO DEVELOP THE REALLY EASY TO
COMMUNICATE GOOD AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES THINGS WE COULD JUST
SEND OUT CONSTANTLY REMINDED
PEOPLE LOVE. AS IT CAN GET
TRYING TO GET AN EFFORT TO
NARROW DOWN THE SOURCES OF
FELONIES PROBLEM SO WE ENCOURAGE
GROWERS IN DEERFIELD AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE TOLD THEM IF THEY
DIDN'T ALREADY KNOW THEY NEEDED
TO AGGRESSIVELY MANAGE
THROUGHOUT. THE NEEDED TO
AGGRESSIVELY MANAGE WEEDS
BECAUSE THE WEEDS CAN BE
RESERVOIRS FOR THE VIRUS ONLY
HOLDING TO PARTICIPATE IN
REPORTING THE DISEASE SO THAT WE
COULD SEE IF THERE WAS- DISEASE
. IMPACT OR BILL THE WHITE
DROPPED ABOUT MORE UNDER MORE
ABOUT HOW THE DISEASE MOVING TO
THE LAST. SOME OF THE OTHER
ACTION WE WERE AROUND WE HAVE
BEEN NOT FEEL BUT IN OUR NATION
AREAS SO WE WORK WITH THE ACT
MISSIONER. WHO- ON THE
RESTRICTED MATURE PERMIT THAT
EVERYTHING HAS. THE BEGINNING OF
THE SEASON TO REMOTE THEM OF THE
AND OF WE ALSO- BACK
COMMISSIONER HELP WITH THE PRO
WHERE WE COULD IN ANY EXACTLY WE
DON'T LET. WE WERE WITH CALTRANS
TOGETHER- RIGHT AWAY ON ALONG
THE ONE WHO YOUR- AND HE REDUCE
WE HOLD MEETINGS AND CORRIDOR.
BACK I WOULD SAY WOULD PROBABLY
ONLY A MODERATE SENATE AND BASS
AND WE EVEN PAY HAVING SOME ONLY
TIME OUR CELL IN ANY AREA WHERE
WE KNEW THERE HAD BEEN A LOT. OF
THE- HE ALSO WORKED WITH FIRING
. AND CITY OF LEADERS OFFICIAL.
ARE NOT ROAD YOU CAN GET MEDIAN
MODEL TO GET. WE NOT GOT AREAS
SUCH AS SOLAR PANEL AND WE ALSO
WERE WITH THE- YOU MAY SURE THAT
WE CAN GET ACCESS TO ANY WE
ISSUED. ON THEIR RIGHT OF WAY.
OTHER THING EVERYDAY. YOUR WHO
HAVE GROUNDING MORE THAN AREA OF
THE VAN MORE VERY CLOSE SCHEDULE
AROUND HERE TO RELOCATE PLANTING
TO AVOID. I HAVE A THE MOST
DISEASE LACK YEAR TO IT IN THE
FALL WHEN- THE PROP WAS WORD.
AND THEIR DEPLOYMENT AMOUNT
AVAILABLE BUT THERE ARE SOME HER
. OF LETTER THAT- I READ AT
LEAST SOMEWHAT TALLER CAMPEON
ALL THAT WAS NOT AS SOON AS IT
WOULDN'T AVAIL. AT THE NOT WAY
OF. BLOWING PROGRESS OF THIS
DOWN- EVERYTHING YOU NEED. WE
NEED TO WIN EVERY WILL REALLY ON
TOP OF THE- MANAGE. WE ARE
APPLIED FOR SECTION TWENTY FOUR
G. OR MEDIA OR IN THE TORAK. TO
GIVE US ANOTHER MADE HERE.
THAT'S AFFECTED THE MR BY ON.
FOR INDUSTRY WOULD GRANTED. I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT-
THE CURRENT PAYMENT THE NEW
SENATE AT. WE ALSO WITH IRE FOR.
THE COMMUNICATION THAT WE NEW.
TO CONTROL- THREAT AND MAY HAVE
THAT. ON TO- REGISTER ON. WE
GOTTA STAY IN OUR IN A WAY FOR
MY SIDE HAD SOME ACTIVITY NOT A
BUT ACT IN YES MA'AM. PROVIDERS
IS LIKELY BETTER THAT WE HAD
THAT. ONLY GIVE A PROBLEM
STATEMENT THAT WE HANDLE MORE
MEETING PRO BY INNOVATORS WHO
THEY MIGHT IDEA. THAT WOULD HELP
WITH THE PRICE. SO WE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH DAVID NOT REALLY
KNOWING WHAT WE WERE GOING TO
GET- IN RESPONSE TO. THE ACTIONS
TAKEN AND- WHATEVER ELSE MOTHER
NATURE MIGHT THROW AT IT THIS
SEASON. EXACTLY WHERE YOU WANT.
IS REPAID CAN WE WERE SEEN FROM
VIRUS BUT IT WAS ONLY ON THE
EDGES OF THE FIELD. AND SO WE
KNEW WE HAD A REPORT FROM THE
GET GO THIS YEAR BUT WE WERE
FORTUNATE THAT FOR THE MOST PART
IT STAYED RIGHT THERE WE IN THE
EARLY AND MID SEASON DEALS WE
DID NOT. HE A LACK. OF THE
DISEASE SPREADING. BUT THAT'S
NOT TO SAY DIDN'T IS THE- IN
ORDER. FIELD THAT HAS. THAT WAS
LOCAL NEXT. HER KERR THEY HAVE A
WE REALLY. BIG GREEN. AND WE
ONLY DONE THE BUYER AND THE-
WERE THE- AND IN THE MOVE ENDS
DOWNLANDS INTO THAT ORDER VAN
FIELD AND YOUR MAIL IT. SO WE
HAVE ALREADY IS NOT SAY THAT WE
DID NOT THIS. PART OF WHAT WE
DID THIS YEAR. WHAT IS YOUR MOM
. THE. IT IS SEEN THROUGHOUT
THIS NEED WE A RECORD SAM OF
GROWER THROUGHOUT THE BALLOT-
REPORT ON THE- AND WE- THOSE
RECALL SO CAN WHERE THAT SPOT
FOR DEVELOPING. SO TWENTY ONE
ONE WOULD NOT THREE YEARS TWENTY
TWENTY LIGHTS. BUT WE LIKE WHEN
YOU BUSY WE HAD A- ONE OF ALL
THAT IS TO WITH THAT WE SOME I'M
AT THE- AND YOUR NUMBER- WE
THINK THERE'S- INTO. SOMETHING
IN THE CHURCH OF TO PER LOSS
HERE. WE THAT OUR GAME-
PRODUCTION WOULD IS FAR MORE
IMPACT THEY- PRINTER. IN THE- WE
KNOW THAT EVERYBODY HAD VERY HAD
MANAGE CAUGHT. WE KNOW THAT THE
DISEASE WAS MUCH WORSE IN THE
FALL WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
THE YEAR BEFORE AND WE KNOW FROM
A SAMPLING THAT WAS DONE.
DISEASED PLANTS IN MANY CASES
HAVE BEEN. I WANTED TO BE PART
OF THE- AHEAD REPAIRING THEM ALL
THE SAME PLANS. HEY MERRY IF I
COULD INTERRUPT REALLY QUICKLY-
YOU MADE REFERENCE TO THE
INCREASED COSTS FROM PEST
MANAGEMENT HAVE. ARE YOU KNOW
ARE THERE ANY OUTCOMES- FROM.
YOU KNOW THE INTENSITY THAT HAS
BEEN INVESTED IN THAT PASSED
MANAGEMENT. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THE FACT THAT THAT
ATTITUDE. YES HOW YES HOW YOU
KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE HAVE YOU
KNOW. THOSE TREATMENTS BEEN YOU
KNOW WHAT SO WHAT HAS BEEN THE
OUTCOME HAS IT HAS IT WORKED HAS
YOU KNOW HAVE YOU HAVE AT YOUR
HAS. HAS PROGRESS BEEN MADE. I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO NEED SOME
OF THAT- A LITTLE LATER WITH THE
SINUSES YOU ARE. ANDREA SO.
WE'RE THAN ME STORE I THINK I'M
THE WAY AND HAVE THEM COME TO
YOU WHAT WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
DIRECTOR COPULATIONS YEAR. MAKES
ITS FARM. YEAH SURE- SO WHAT
CERTAINLY ONE OF HERE IT WAS A
BETTER HEARING KNOW OF THE THAT
. TO THE ONE THIS IS ACTIVE-
MANAGE. THAT IS A WE A HUGE
CENTER. ONE LANDING THE GOAL
THREE IT'S HARD ON ONE
INDIVIDUAL IF IT AN IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE WILL A NEW THING.
BUT IF YOU THE GOAL TO BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT DOWN. ONLY USUALLY
WHICH IS BUT NO SEND. AND ALL OF
COULD NOT CAKE WE IS ONE THE OLD
THINGS AVAILABLE FOR. ORGANIC
PRODUCE. AND THEY'RE BEEN YEARS
RECORD. BECOMING RESISTANT TO
THIS MATERIAL SO WE THINK WE'RE
OUT OF OUR OWN TIME WITHOUT
MATERIAL. SO I WE ALSO GET LOT
OF DAMAGE THAT WE ADOPTED OUR
PLAN. BUT WHAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
BE A- PLANTING WAS AT BUYER
MOVED US. SO INSTEAD OF BEING.
CONCENTRATED ON IN IN THAT LACKS
YEAR THE TRYING TO ON THE FIELD
. OF THEIR THIS YEAR BECAUSE
WERE LOT OF LETTER WITH NEW
SHIELD. YES THING I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT. FROM
BASICALLY THE- C. WE A LONG OR
TEMP. WHICH WE DON'T KNOW THAT
EVERY YEAR WE THINK THAT. THE
FULLER NORMAL. HAVE ALSO ADDED
IMPACT ON YOUR HOSPITAL. WE ALSO
KNOW THE MOM POINT TO THE FACT
THAT WE A WARM FOR. AND NOW
WOULD. THAT WE HAD WE GOT LUCKY
THIS YEAR THE STAR OF THE
WEATHER WE VERY BUT WE- EXPECT
THAT TO BE IN. TO THIS. SO I.
WRAP UP BY THE NAME THAT WE ALL
I THINK AGREE THAT WE NEED DIRE
BASEBALL TERM- AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF THINGS WE DON'T UNDER. A
THING THE DESIGN HIS WE'RE GOING
TO. SPEAKING WITH YOU TODAY ARE
GOING TO BE BETTER THAN ME. AT
THE FINAL WHISTLE OF THOSE. BUT
WE NEED TO SUPPORT AND THEN. NEW
ALWAYS LINE SOLUTIONS AND WE'RE
- HEARING WAYNE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE FAR THAT. THAT YOU WERE TO
BE AND- HAPPY WITH IF TO BE. TO
THE- OUR TRYING- IN NOT IF. SO
ONE AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT WE GOING TO TAKE OFF OF
THEIR INTENSE AFTER NINE TO THE
BY OF THE AND- SOLUTIONS SURE
HELLO I AM. SURE AND- I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR MAKING US OF A
PLEASE HOLD ON THE BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO LOOK. BY REALLY PER. YOU
I JUST WILL YOU KNOW. WHICH ONE
IS A THING YOU FOR. REALLY
HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPACTS- I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT IS CONCERNING ESPECIALLY
WITH THE PYTHIUM WILT AS I
MENTIONED IN. HIS OPENING
REMARKS THAT I MADE IS THAT IT
LEAVES BEHIND THESE PATHOGENS
THAT COULD REMAIN IN THE SOIL A
FOR YEARS. AND YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE MITIGATION MEASURES THAT
HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN ESPECIALLY
DISKIN AND I'M NOT SURE IF I
MISTER NOT BUT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT. THE YOU KNOW THE CURRENT
IMPACTS- GROWERS AND FARMS THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. DO YOU HAVE
IN IN YOU KNOW AN IDEA AN
ESTIMATE AS FAR AS THE NUMBER OF
ACRES. THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE PYTHIUM WELL. I DON'T
HAVE THE DATA AND OPINION WORLD.
MORE THE DATE IS ON I. N. BI YOU
CAN GET THE ENERGY. MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY. WE FOUND
THAT A LOT OF THE PEST CONTROL
ADVISORS WERE HESITANT. TO
SACRAMENTO. THE- BEYOND THIS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE IF. THERE
WAS FAMILY TO LAUGHTER ACCOUNT
FOR BEFORE THEIR WILLING CHECK
THAT. BUT WE KNOW THAT THE TO DO
. IN MANY DECADES. OCCUR
TOGETHER BUT WE DO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE SEEING.
ONE OR THE OTHER BUT NOT FULL.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND SO
PLEASE HOLD ON THE LINE AND THE
NEXT- MEMBER THE PANEL IS
RICHARD SMITH WHO IS A FARMER
VISOR WITH YOU SEE A AND R.
HANDLES VEGETABLE CROP US SOME
PRODUCTION AND WE'D THE SCIENCE
RICHARD ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I'M
HERE OKAY. THEY ARE FANTASTIC.
WELL TAKE IT AWAY RETURN IT'S
ALL YOURS. I NEED TO GET HIS- WE
NEED TO GET HIS WHY YEAH NO
PROBLEM. FIGURE OUT HOW. TO THIS. YEAH YEAH THE. OKAY SO GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEN RIVAS
AND- SO I'M GONNA JUST TRY TO
GIVE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE OF
THESE- TO DISEASES AND THEN-
WILL BE GOING INTO MORE DETAIL-
BUT OTHER PANELISTS ABOUT THE
DISEASE BUT THIS- YOU KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING WE KNOW WHEN YOU'RE%
DEALING WITH THE BIOLOGICAL
SYSTEM THEY KIND OF SURPRISE
YOU- BECAUSE WE'VE HAD I IN IS
TO BE IN THE LATEST VALLEY YOU
KNOW THE FIRST IDENTIFIED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN PICKING WILL-
WITH FIRST. BASICALLY RECOGNIZED
TO BE HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN BUT- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND- IT'S NOT
LIKE THEY JUST SHOWED UP LAST
YEAR BUT- THEY DID EXPRESS
THEMSELVES IN A IN A
PARTICULARLY- YOU KNOW
CATASTROPHIC FASHION LAST YEAR
AND- YOU KNOW IT WAS IT WAS- AS
MERRY SAID IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS
SOMETHING I'VE NEVER SEEN I'VE
BEEN AT THIS FOR THIRTY SIX
YEARS AND- I'VE NEVER SEEN A
DISEASE- ANAHIT AND CANNOT WAIT-
DOWNFIELD IN THE WAY. THAT THAT
IT HAD- AS AS WE MENTION YOU
KNOW THIS HAVE BEEN RE. TO THE
HEAT SPELL- BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
HAD HE IN THE PAST YOU KNOW IN
THAT IN THE IN TIMES IT IS THE
THIS UP. BUT SO THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOMEONE UNCERTAINTY AT
THE WHY IT'S GOING UP AND I
THINK MERRY'S POINT ABOUT
RELYING ON A COOL SEASON IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
IT WAS ACTUALLY KIND OF UNUSUAL
THE COOL LAST YEAR AND- WHY THAT
WAS- I DON'T THINK WE CAN COUNT
ON IT FOR- YOU KNOW. THAT
FORCIBLE FUTURE. AND- SO THIS IS
JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME- CLOSE UPS
OF IT- YOU KNOW YOU THE AYE AND
IF HE GIVES YOU THAT- KIND OF
BIRTH SITTING THE PRODUCT-
TISSUE ON THE OLDER LEAD AND-
BUT IT ALSO HAS A VERY AND WE
SEEN WHERE SOMETIMES THE PLANTS
LOOK NORMAL NINETY. INTO THEM
AND THEN THE INTERNAL AREA IS-
HIGHLY AFFECTED AND SO YOU KNOW
ALL OF THIS IS COURSES
UNMARKETABLE. AND FIFTY WILL
EXPRESS ITSELF DIFFERENTLY IN
THAT- IT DOES WILL DOWN THE PLAN
AS AS THE NAME IMPLIES. AND A
LOT OF TIMES IT'LL SHOW UP ON
THE BOTTOM INTO THE FIELD FOR
BUT IT CAN ALSO IN SEVERE
SITUATIONS OF COURSE- TAKE- AT
KEEP GOING IN AND CAN BE SEVERE
IN IN ALL PARTS OF THE FIELD.
YOU KNOW THE OTHER LEAVES- WILL
DOWN AND THEN THE INTERLEAVED
WITH HIM TO BE- GREEN. STILL
UNTIL THE PLAN FINALLY DIED AND
THEN. WITH YOU- WHEN YOU START
DIGGING AND LOOKING AT THE- THE
ROOT SYSTEM YOU SEE THE ACTUAL
RIDING. IN AND PRIOR TO THIS-
OUT YET IF THE- YOU KNOW THE-
SURGEON OF HIM WE'VE REALLY HAD
A ROOF RIDING. ORGANISM ON THE
PLANET SO THIS IS THIS IS THE
NEW- CHEN NOMINA THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH HE HAD THINK
THEY'LL ROUTE THE CROWN BUT NOT
THE ROOT. AND SO YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF LIKE THE CONTROL
OPTIONS AGAIN THIS OF THE- TALK
ABOUT IN MORE DETAIL BUT- THE
THREAT- WHICH SPREAD SIGN IN THE
MIDDLE THIS ADDS A LEVEL OF
COMPLEXITY. WHERE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH- YOU KNOW INTO POPULATION
AND THEIR RESPONSE TO WHETHER.
OTHERS WANT THE TEMPERATURES.
AND. AND THEN OF COURSE THE
CONTROL MEASURES. AND THING IS
ALSO. BY BY THEM AS YOU WELL
KNOW IN THE LATEST VALLEY IN THE
AFTERNOON WE HAVE- YOU KNOW
NORTHERLY WINDS THAT COME DOWN
THE VALLEY AND EVEN SEX ARE
EASILY. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE THE MATERIALS THAT ARE
THAT ARE BEING USED THEIR THEIR
MORE MORE OF A CONTACT TYPE
MATERIAL. RATHER THAN A SYSTEMIC
MATERIAL FOR THEM. TO GET
COVERAGE AND IN DEAL YOU KNOW
NOT BE POPULATIONS DOWN ONCE THE
POPULATION IS HIGH IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT ONCE THE PLANTS GET
BIGGER. AND SO EVEN IN IN
CONVENTIONAL- IT IT IS- WITH THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE TEAM-
INSECTICIDE THE VERY WAS
REFERRING TO IT IN A VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONTROL THEM. AND
AS MARY MENTIONED WE WERE REALLY
HELPFUL TO GET THIS- THE TWENTY
FORTY FOR TORAK. BUT THAT WAS
DENIED. AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
AND- THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN US
ANOTHER TOOL AND THEN ALSO WITH
HELP BUT IN- IN INSTANCE
SAFEGUARDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RESISTANCE TO THE EXISTING- THE
INSECTICIDE THAT WE HAVE.
ORGANIC PRODUCTION AND ASSEMBLY
SALLY I THINK IS YOU KNOW- THE
AG COMMISSIONER'S REPORT FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY JUST CAME OUT
ABOUT A MONTH AGO. AND IT DID IS
IT REALLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GROWING- EE I ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
CHARTING THE GROWTH OF THE
ORGANIC INDUSTRY SINCE THE- THE
EARLY NINETIES WHEN THEY
STARTED- KEEPING TRACK OF THE-
THE VALUE. AND IN THE LAST- BUT
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS THE NUMBER
OF THE NUMBERS HAVE JUST BEEN
INCREASING DRAMATICALLY. AND
THERE'S A VERY VERY STRONG
MARKET- FOR CANADA. AND WE'RE
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. AND AFTER THE TOTAL
ORGANIC- INDUSTRY AND SO IT'S A
VERY SERIOUS BUSINESS HERE-
THERE'S NO- YOU KNOW KIND OF-
IT'S NOT LIKE LOOKED DOWN UPON
IN ORGANIC IS PART OF THE
BUSINESS THIS IS A GIFT IS
ANNABELLE- ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WE HAVE THOUGH IS SAFEGUARDING
THIS INDUSTRY FROM- ISSUES LIKE
THIS. WHERE THIS COMES ALONG AND
THEN IT'S MERRY MENTION NOW
YOU'RE DOWN TO ONE MATERIAL TO
TRY AND DEAL WITH IT AND- THAT'S
A VERY PRECARIOUS SITUATION- TO-
IT BEYOND THAT WE HAVE VERY
LIMITED. OPTIONS FOR DEALING
WITH- THIS TAKE A TRIP IN-
ORGANIC PRODUCTION AND THEN THE
RESULTING- ISSUES WITH BINEBI
THAT. COME ABOUT AS A PART OF
THAT- AND THEN ONE MORE THING IS
MUCH. OF WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH- WITH GROWERS IN
CONTROLLING THE WEED HOSTS. AND
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
DURING THE WINTER WHEN THE
LETTUCE IS NOT- PRESENT IN THE
PRODUCTION FIELD THE VIRUSES
OVERWINTERING. IN A RESIDENT
PLAN AND WEEDS AND GO FOR IT AND
IT'S MERRY- LAID OUT AB- BENEFIT
EXCELLENT JOB OF ORGANIZING THE
GROWTH OF FORMING A TASK FORCE
IS WORKING WITH CALTRANS AND
OTHER AGENCIES. AND DOING
EDUCATION NEEDS- FOR THE GROWTH
TO MAINTAIN- AT THIS IS VIDEO OF
WE CONTROL IT THEY CANNOT FARMS. AND ROUNDING AREA. AND THEN-
IF WILL IS TRICKY HAS AS-
MENTION YOU KNOW A FULL BORDERS
IN THE IS THE- OF- PLANT
PATHOLOGY. THEY'RE GOAL BORDERS
. ARE TRICKY BECAUSE YOU'RE
DEALING. WITH THE MASSIVE FOIL
THAT THESE PLANTS ARE GROWING
IN. AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
A BUNCH OF FLIGHT CONTROL- NEEDS
BUT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
THE MATERIALS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE TOP PART OF THE ROOT
SYSTEM TO GET EFFECTIVE. ALL AND
SO WE YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN RUSTRATED- IN IN A CAMP.
AND LOOKING AT THAT PARTICULAR
THAT PARTICULAR OPTION. AND SO
YOU KNOW WITH THE SB ONE
SEVENTEEN VERY EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD AT A GOOD
CLIP. TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GOOD- INCREASE OUR UNDERSTANDING
THE EPIDEMIOLOGY BIOLOGY OF
THESE DISEASES. AND TO MITIGATE
THEIR IMPACT. AND YOU KNOW TO
FURTHER- EVALUATE- VARIOUS-
PESTICIDE BUT ALSO BIOLOGICAL
BECAUSE THE THERE'S A THERE'S A
GOOD. A LOT OF- DEVELOPMENT IN-
MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY ON
BIOLOGICAL WE WANT TO DEFINITELY
LOOK AT THOSE TYPE THE MATERIAL.
AND THEN OF COURSE- CULTURAL
PRACTICES SUCH AS THE IRRIGATION
MANAGEMENT THE FOURTH AND THEN
IT'S MERRY MENTIONED UP-
RESISTANT IS IT SOMETHING THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE. EVALUATED
AND THEN BETTER UNDERSTAND. I
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATIVE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVEN. I THANK
YOU RICHARD REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK AND- YOUR COMMENTS
AND- THE PRESENTATION AND I
THINK ON THIS LAST POINT
RESEARCH NEEDS. YOU KNOW AS IF
YOU CAN REALLY BRIEFLY SPEAK AS
YOU KNOW AS TO HOW THIS CURRENT
FUNDING FOR THIS- THIS PREVIOUS
BUDGET YEAR. YOU KNOW HOW YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT YOU KNOW. THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE USED IN
AND HOW MUCH MORE FUNDING IF ANY
IS GOING TO BE NEEDED DOWN THE
ROAD AND WHAT MORE SHOULD OR
COULD WE BE DOING AS A STATE. IN
ADDITION TO JUST FUNDING. YEAH
WELL I THINK- YOU KNOW CURRENTLY
AS WE SPEAK THE CALL FOR
PROPOSALS FOR THAT THAT FUNDING
FOR FROM SB ONE SEVENTY. IS
OPEN. TO FOR PEOPLE TO BE
APPLYING FOR THE- THE FUN AND SO
WE'RE GONNA- I THINK THERE'S A
LOT O- RESEARCHERS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE. YOU KNOW EXPLORE
YOU KNOW PUTTING IN FOR FUNDING
TO- TAKE A GOOD CAREFUL LOOK AT
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW LIKE THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND- BIOLOGY OF
THESE OF THESE ORGANISMS. AND IN
CONTROL- METHOD MEASURES. SO
THOSE- THAT THAT'S ALL GOING TO
GETTING FUNDED- AND IN UNDER WAY
IN IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHICH IS
VERY EXCITING. AND I THINK THE
REALITY IS WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS BECAUSE YOU KNOW. AS YOU
KNOW ASSEMBLY REVISITS YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A BIOLOGICAL
SYSTEM. AND IF IT IS THE BIOLOGY
IF THE WEATHER. AND ALL OF THESE
OTHER COMPONENTS IN INTERACTING
THAT- THAT MAKE THIS COMPLEX SO
YOU KNOW CAN WE SOLVE THIS WHOLE
THING. YOU KNOW WITH THIS- FIRST
INFUSION OF MONEY- YOU KNOW IT'S
PROBABLY OPTIMISTIC TO THINK
THAT THAT MIGHT HAPPEN MAY BE
OVERLY OPTIMISTIC I GUESS I
SHOULD SAY. THE BIG THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN IN THAT THAT THAT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING SO CERTAINLY
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE A
CONTINUED. A NECESSITY. AND THEN
IN TERMS OF STATE- YOU KNOW WE-
YOU KNOW WE'VE APPLIED FOR
SECTION EIGHTEEN. AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND SO FORTH AND SO-
YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY- CAN YOU
SEND. IN TERMS OF TRYING TO GET
THOSE KINDS OF REQUESTS- GRANTED
YOU KNOW- AS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
. THIS IS SOMETHING TO COME TO
MY MIND. I THANK YOU RICHARD
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
RESPONSES- AND THEN THE FINAL
PANELIST WHO I BELIEVE IS THERE
WITH YOU GUYS AS WELL AS MARK
MASON WITH NATURE'S REWARD. SO
MARK- IF YOU'RE READY TO GO FEEL
FREE. THANK YOU. I OKAY SO- I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GIVE A LITTLE
BIT OF INSIGHT- FROM THE FIELD
SO- I'M A PASS CONTROLLED VISORS
WELL THEY CERTIFIED CROP ADVISER
I WORK FOR A LARGE CONTAINER
SHIPPER HERE IN SALINAS VALLEY-
SO I'M JUST GOING HAVING GIPSON
POINTS THAT I FEEL. GROWERS IN
GENERAL FEEL LIKE WHETHER THEIR
CONVENTIONAL GROWERS FOR ORGANIC
GROWERS AND- BUT- I BELIEVE IS
THAT WE FEEL LIKE THIS IS A TRUE
DISASTER- AND SAW THAT THE SOME
OF THE REASONS HERE WHY I FEEL
THAT WAY AND YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST THING THAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW. AS GROWERS IS THAT WE
ARE CHANGING WHERE WE PLANT-
IT'S A HUGE GAPS IN GAME TIME WE
STARTED BY. ROTATING OUR LETTUCE
AROUND THE RANCH IS TRYING TO
AVOID WHAT WE THOUGHT MAYBE THE
PROBLEM AT THE END OR I AND S.
B. AND SO WE MOVED OUR CLIENT
TEAMS. IF WE COULD THROUGHOUT
THE RANCH TO TRY TO AVOID THESE
PROBLEMS- AND FROM THERE AS IT
IS AS- AS THEY THE DISEASE GOT
HIT SEVENTIES LOCATIONS. THAT WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD AVOID IT WE
STARTED MOVING THE OTHER
COUNTIES- AND THEN FROM THERE
THESE OTHER COUNTIES SO YOU'RE
TALKING SAN BENITO OR SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY- ALSO ARE STARTING TO GET
THIS DISEASE. SO NOW THE GROWERS
AND SHIPPERS ARE LOOKING TO
OTHER AREAS- THAT WOULD BE
EITHER OUTSIDE OF THE STATE OR
EVEN OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY DOWN TO
MEXICO TO TRY TO GROW LETTUCE TO
AVOID THESE DISEASES. SO WHAT
WHAT CONCERNS ME ABOUT THAT IS
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT- STAFF AND
EMPLOYEES THAT WE HAVE BAD THIS
IS A JOB LOSS SITUATION WE'VE
GOT FOUR INDUSTRY IF WE START
MOVING OUR LETTUCE PRODUCTION
OUTSIDE OF THE AREA- SO I. THAT
AT WE BEGIN AS THIS THING GETS
MORE ITS OWN A MATTER TIME THE-
ALL OF OUR RANCH BEGAN INFECTED
WITH PETER PYTHIUM R. I. N. S.
B. WE'RE DOING OUR BEST TO
CONTROL THE WEEDS. AND THE RAMPS
BYE IT SEEMS LIKE WE CANNOT OUT
RUN THIS THING- EVERY TIME WE
TRY TO MAKE OUR BEST STAFF.
TOWARDS TRYING TO AVOID IT AND-
IT'S AN EXACT HONEST AND WE GET
EITHER A PARTIAL WIPE OUT OF THE
FIELD OR WE GET ENTIRE LIFE OUT
OF THE FIELD. AND THAT'S JUST
IT'S DEVASTATING FOR THE GROWER
AND THE INDUSTRY AND SO IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION THAT
WERE PUT IN ON THIS SO THEN WHAT
DO WE DO- YOU KNOW. I FEEL LIKE
SOMETIMES. THAT WORKS WORKS OF
FLYING BLIND ON THIS- WHICH I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
TERM BY. WHAT HAPPENS IS WE IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS IS THAT
PAST CONTROL ADVISORS. MAIN
POSSIBLY OVER REACTING AGAIN
THIS WOULD BE EITHER ORGANIC AND
CONVENTIONAL- WHEN. THERE'S A
PROBLEM THAT WE DON'T KNOW
REALLY HOW TO SOLVE IT- WE TEND
TO. OVER OVER REACTED- GROWERS
ARE SCARED THAT THERE GONNA LOSE
THEIR CROPS AND SO I THINK IT'S
A VERY- IMPORTANT. ISSUE THAT WE
GOT TO THINK ABOUT AS FAR AS
PESTICIDE USE- THIS IS NOT THE
RIGHT WAY TO CONTROL THIS. AND
WE JUST NEED TO REALIZE YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING SO- SO
ON THAT NOTE YOU KNOW WE'VE
TRIED FOR SOME SECTION EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR SEIZE PERSON NEED
TEN MYSTERY- BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
OF THIS RESISTANCE TO MAP THE
MALE. OR THE SPEND NO CENTERS
FOR NELSON AS MERRY TALKED
ABOUT- WE NEED A ROTATION WE
NEED WE NEED SOMETHING THAT.
PASSED CONTROL ADVISORS CAN
ROTATE- WE JUST NEED SOMETHING
NEW IN THE TOOLBOX WE'VE ONLY
GOT REALLY YOU KNOW A FEW FEW
OPTIONS. AND YOU KNOWWE NEED TO
WE NEED TO FIND MORE. MORE TOOLS
THAT WE CAN. USE AS PAST CONTROL
OF FIGHTERS- YOU KNOW THE END OF
MY LIFE POINT IS KNOW THIS THING
IS PUMP- WHEN WITH ROTATION AND
WEEDS AND PERHAPS AN IRRIGATION.
THE IT FEELS LIKE- YOU KNOW WE
REALLY DON'T KNOW. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WHAT TO DO NEXT SO WE NEED
RESEARCH BIG TIME- I FEEL LIKE.
I FEEL LIKE THAT THE THAT WE
JUST WE DON'T KNOW WE'RE NOT
THAT MUCH FURTHER AHEAD NOW THAN
WE WERE YOU KNOW A FEW YEARS AGO
I MEAN WE'VE MADE STRIDES BUT WE
NEED MORE RESEARCH AND AGAIN
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S VERY COMPLEX.
I THINK WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THIS TASK FORCE IS THAT
IT IS VERY COMPLEX AND IT'S MORE
COMPLEX THAN WE THOUGHT IT WAS
AND SO THAT'S WHY I MEAN. YOU
KNOW THIS RESEARCH IS JUST GONNA
BE OUT WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM SO-
YOU KNOW THAT'S IT AS SHORT
SLIDE BUT THAT'S- THAT'S KIND OF
THE TAKE FROM THE FIELD. THANK
YOU MARK I THINK YOU KNOW YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS IS
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS IS A
SERIOUS SERIOUS PROBLEM. AND
THERE ARE NO CLEAR CUT- SOME
STRATEGIES OR SOME SOLUTIONS ON
ON HOW WE MANAGE AND HOW WE. WE-
ARE GONNA MITIGATE THIS PROBLEM-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S- IT'S CONCERNING-
LOOK YOU KNOW AS YOU MENTIONED-
JUST LEARNING ABOUT THE GROWING
FOOTPRINT. OF D. YOU KNOW THESE
IMPACTED- FARMS AND- AND SITES.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA AS FAR AS-
YOU KNOW THE IMPACTS OF I. N. S.
B. AND IT'S A PITY IN WEALTH AND
OTHER PARTS OF. OF OUR STATE YOU
KNOW OUTSIDE OF. THE DID THE
MONTEREY AND SAN BENITO REGION.
SO I YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBERS I CAN JUST TELL
YOU WHAT I'VE HEARD BROUGH AND
INDUSTRY IS THAT IT IS DOWN IN
THE IN THE AREA- BUT I DON'T
KNOW HOW BAD. IT IS- BUT THEY
ARE THE FROM MY CONTACTS ARE
SAYING THAT THEY DO YOU SEE THE
I. N. S. B. DOWN THE YUMA
ARIZONA AREA YES. I WOULD ALSO
ADDED- OUR NEIGHBORS IN THE
SANTA MARIA AREA ARE WATCHING
THIS VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE THEIR
PRODUCTION- SITUATION VERY
SIMILAR TO HEAR ANY THEY HAVE
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF THE VIRUS IN
PAST YEARS THEY'VE ALSO ADDED
OPPOSE ANOTHER VIRUS CALLED ME
WAS BAD WILL SO THEY'RE WATCHING
ON IT VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE POTENTIAL IS THERE. FOR
THEM TO HAVE A FURIOUS HE'S USED
TO THAT AS FAR AS WE KNOW THEY
HAVEN'T HAD THE SEVERITY OF
DISEASE THAT WE'VE SEEN. IN THIS
AREA. WHAT THE YOU FOR THAT- AND
- AND AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU ALL MAKING THE TIME- AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND PANEL- AND I'M NOT SURE
IS THE SECOND PANEL ALSO THERE
IN THE ROOM. FANTASTIC AND SO
THIS SECOND PANEL- THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND SOLUTIONS
FUTURE RESEARCH AND FUNDING. AND
SO THE THREE MEMBERS OF THE
PANEL R. JENNIFER CLARKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAFY GREENS
RESEARCH BOARD WE HAVE A DOCTOR
ON. DOOR AREAS A PLANT.
PATHOLOGIST AT CSU MONTEREY- AND
THEN WE HAVE- MISTER DANIEL K.
POSSIBLE. HASEGAWA I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISSED- MISPRONOUNCED A
NAME. WHO IS A PHD RESEARCH
ENTOMOLOGIST- AND SO- WITH THAT
WHOEVER ON THE PANEL WANTS TO GO
FIRST PLEASE FEEL FREE. THANK
YOU I'M JENNIFER GARNER I WILL
GO FIRST AND HAS HE HAD UP AND
WILL SAY THE BEST FOR LAST WITH
WILL BEARD THE RESEARCHERS. TELL
ME WHERE. MAKE IT. YEAH IN ORDER
TO EARN. SORRY I NEED TO LEARN
WORK. THE MORE. OPEN THE BOX. WE. FIGURED IT OUT OF TIME AND WE
ARE CLOSED. AGAIN REQUIRED AND I
WANT TO THANK YU FOR HAVING US. AND I. THINK I HAD IT OKAY WE
GO. SO I JUST WANTED TO GIVE A
QUICK HISTORY ABOUT- BELIEVING
RESEARCH PROGRAM AND I'M SORRY
IF YOU ALREADY ARE AWARE OF THIS
IT IS A MANDATORY PROGRAM- AND
WE ASK THAT HAMMERS. AND FORMER
ONE DEVELOP WILL WAS- INITIATED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND FANS AND IT ISN'T FOR A
VERY LONG TIME AND OVER THE
COURSE OF HISTORY IT'S CHANGED
ITS NAME A COUPLE OF TIMES
DEFENSIVE DRIVER IN. THEN
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE. COME ON
BOARD ON THE MARKET- THE
HAMBURGER FROM AROUND WE HAVE A
- FOR AT THE UNIVERSITY MEMBER
AND OKAY NUMBER WOULD REPRESENT
THREE GET- GOING TO WANT TO MAKE
IS THERE'S FOR ALL OF-
HAMBURGERS INTERNET AREA
ANALYSTS SAY THE THREE AREAS. I
REMEMBER TOTAL OF SIXTY. POINT
WHERE AND A PROGRAM. SOME OF OUR
CALENDARS WERE TALKING TODAY-
FINANCING IF THE I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR THAT. THE
RESEARCHERS IT IS A DRAFT AND WE
GET RAIN I PRODUCTION AREAS. WE
HAVE THINK TO CONCERN- REGULAR
OVER. AND OF THE BORDER IN THE
MAN WITH THAT ORDER. IN THE
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT- MORE HAVE
ONLY ARE AND- MANY THIS IS. NEW
INFORMATION FOR ANY IDEA BUT WE
HAVE ANY INFORMATION AS THE
SENATE TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES ME FOR
ABOUT- YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THOSE
EVEN WITH ORGANIC PRODUCTION BUT
WE DO HAVE OTHER PASS. IN THE
AREA YOU KNOW THAT IF THAT WE
DELIVER ANALYTIC PRODUCTION
OTHER THAN AND THREATS- AND WE
ALSO HAVE OTHER SOBERING
DISEASES AND VIRUSES. THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO TACKLE SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF ARE YOU
SEE AN APARTMENT BUYERS
ESPECIALLY WE REALLY HAVE RELIED
ON IN THE PAST. AND WALDRON. NOT
SAYING ABOUT HOW MUCH WE ARE TO
HAVE. AN G. P. AND DANIEL HERE
NOW THE NEXT TO WITHOUT THIS
BACK. AND RICHARD WITH WRITTEN-
I KNOW WHERE WE WOULD BE AT THE
END OF. THE HIGHLIGHT WHAT EVERY
FOR- IN. ON AND YOU SEE. THAT
PRIMARY. ARE RESEARCH GO TO AND
THAT WOULD OUR- THAT THE LONG
TERM. TO HELP BUT THE- WITH IN
FACT HAS- WE NEED RESIDENTS THEN
. ALSO NEED. AND MARK TO HELP-
DEAL WITH JUST OTHER INVITE AND
HAPPINESS TALK ABOUT. OR MAKE
MINOR. AND MAYBE POTENTIAL A LOT
OF RAINFALL THE- WATER- YOU CAN
READ HAVE ANOTHER. ANOTHER BY
HERE AND FOLLOW G. IN OUR SECOND
HIGH- SPENDING. WE BELIEVE SOME
OF THE PRIME OF THE BOARD HAS
BEEN INSTEAD. ABOUT WITH VARIETY
HIT THE RESTART AND I THINK YOU
NEED TO GET INTO LAW OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE- YOU MEAN RESEARCHER
CARE WITH FOOD AND. IN THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL FIND. THREE
PROJECTS- ONE HUNDRED OPPOSED
THERE WAS FACTS ARE BY THEIR-
WITH US AND HOME IS LAST IN I
BACK TO THE IS. CURRENTLY THIRTY
THOUSAND AND WE HUNDRED THREE
PROJECT AS WELL- AND YOU DANIEL
PARKER GALA AND YOU CAN DOES NOT
AREAS AND RICHARD SMITH ON ON A
LOT OF THE FLAG. AND HERE'S BY.
SO WE HAVE A TOTAL OF EIGHTY
PROJECT ARE NEEDED TO BUY FOR
THIS- AND AGAIN. HER DATE AND
THEN SO LUCKY TO HAVE THAN. AND
THERE'S A CONTINUING. YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT TO THE OTHER.
CATEGORIES SO I A PERFORMING
ACTION AND BY IN. AREA HE IS
MONITORING AND- I S. B. AN
IMPERIAL- JERRY AT WHEN YOU SEE
HERAND HE YOU KNOW WE'RE FOR
TRYING TO THINGS IN HERE ARE
LOOKING. ABOUT MEETING UNITY
PRIME MINISTER THE LAST TIME I
DID KIND OF YOU CAN BE LOOKING
TO. AND RETURN FOR THE HE GAVE-
I EXCITED ABOUT YOU KNOW NOT
TECHNOLOGY. AND PRECISION AND
THEN SEPARATE ACT WITH IT YOUR
QUESTION ISSUES. I THINK THAT
WAS PRETTY BAD I DO TO SAY- YOU
KNOW DID QUITE. TO NEED. AND
NICE TO GO. TO BY EDITOR TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR YOU KNOW
OUR OUR IS PRETTY. ALL SAID AND
DONE AND I COULD THEY'RE THE
TYPE OF THEIR THIRTY TWO PROJECT
AND IN THIS- YOUR THAT WE THAT
WE'RE FINDING AND IF I FEEL OFF
THOSE BREEDING AND GENETICS- THE
PROJECT IN THE FUNDING DOLLARS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT REALLY- AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR THEY GO TO
OUR NEEDS AND OTHER PROJECT ONE.
ON AVERAGE NUMBER TWO I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU THAT FIGURE
TO SHOW THAT ARE FUNDING SOURCES
PRETTY MODEST- RESEARCHERS OFTEN
USE OUT OF THE WAY TO GATHER
PRELIMINARY DATA AND THEN
PLEASE. TAKE OTHER LARGER
GRANTING FORKLIFT- LARGER GRANT
AND THEY OFFER YOU ACCESS. FOR
MATCHING FUNDS WHICH WILL HELP
THEM GET MORE. MONEY ORDER. SO-
POINT BEING THAT ONE SEVENTY
MONEY. REALLY PERSON. AND WILL
HAVE. HOW I DON'T GET GET
AGAINST ON. THE PROJECT AND HELP
LINE. THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR AND
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW THIS-
BUT IN TO FINDING OUT KNOW OUR
STAFF DID- INITIAL SAYS AND- YOU
KNOW LOOKED AT A FUNDING FOR YOU
KNOW HIS- SOME FUNDING FOR- SOME
PEST DISEASE AND- SOME
PREVENTION AND- OBVIOUSLY IN THE
PAST WITH- SOME SIMILAR ISSUES
THAT. HAVE OCCURRED HERE IN OUR
STATE YOU'VE YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN EFFORTS SUCH AS SELF
ASSESSMENT TO INCREASE FUNDING.
HAS US THE US D. D. D. A. R.
HAVE THEY FIND IN ANY OF THIS
LOCAL RESEARCH AT ALL. IN YOU
NAY I DON'T HAVE ANY DANIEL
MURPHY THERE'S SOME OF THAT I
THINK WHAT I'M GOING. YEAH HEY
MISTER REDUCE THIS IS DANIEL
AUSTRIA AND I'M RESURGENT WITH
USDA IN SALINAS BUT I WILL SAY
THAT WHEN YOU. SHORTER I WON'T
GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT WE
RIGHT PROJECT PLANS IN TERMS OF-
WORK THAT YOU KNOW WE WANT TO DO
AND THAT IS NEEDED AND I'VE-
CONTINUOUSLY WRITTEN IN PROJECTS
THAT. ADDRESS THE I. N. S. B.
INTEREST CHALLENGES SO- IN THAT
SENSE WE ARE RECEIVING SOME
FUNDING- FROM U. S. SKATER
SUPPORT THIS RESEARCH AS WELL.
THAT'S GREAT THANKS DAN. THANK
YOU. YOU AND I WOULD MENTION
AGAIN WE DID SEND OUT THE CALL
FOR PROPOSALS THE BIGGEST REASON
FOR- THE DOLLARS WE WERE
DETERMINED SB WON SEVENTY
ALLOCATION AND PHOTOS- PROPOSAL
ARE DUE DECEMBER FIFTEENTH SO
MANY PROBABLY. I'LL BE RECEIVING
. HOLDEN AND ABOARD NEED AS THE
FIGHT ON. SO REALLY FOR TO.
BEING BACK. BUT WE WERE. THAT'S
GREAT AND JANET- WILL REALLY BE
YOU MAKING TIME FOR US. I CAN
THAT OUT. OKAY AND I. ALL WITHIN
A FULL. COOL. ALL. THANK YOU.
YEAH. OKAY YOU CANNOT APPLY. TO
I THINK. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN AREA- GOOD AFTERNOON-
HOW WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO- SHARE WITH
YOU SOME OF THE- THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING ANA IF IT
AVAILABLE UP LETTERS- BUT YOU
WOULD SEE IN THE ON THE SCREEN
MY NAME IS A BIG PIECE ON THERE
ARE COMING UP WITH THE PROFESSOR
OF PLANT PATHOLOGY- CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY MONTEREY BAY.
AND EVEN THOUGH MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS WORKERS-
BLAME THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
PROBLEM THAT WE ARE FACING HERE-
I DO WANT TO SHOW THIS PICTURE
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT YOU TO TAKE
THEM THE IDEA THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THINGS WENT BACK TO NORMAL
TWENTY TWENTY WAS DEVASTATED BUT
AS YOU CAN SEE IF YOU WERE BORN
OR PLEASE FEEL THESE GROWER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS AS BAD AS
SOARED TWENTY- YOU CAN SEE THAT
THERE IS. ACT OVER LIKE OUT OF A
GENERAL AND WIDESPREAD
DEVASTATION CAUSED BY THIS WOULD
BE FIFTEEN WILL BE SEEN- AND
EVEN THOUGH YOU WE SAW ADDRESS
DURING PART OF THE YEAR LET ME
SEE SHOWING UP WHEN THEY SEE IT
SHOWED UP IN A WAR BECAUSE OF A
MAJOR DAMAGE IN MAJOR OFFICER
INDUSTRY SO I WANTED JUST TO
HIGHLIGHTED THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING- KEEPING
THAT IN MIND THIS FIFTY YEARS
BACK IN IN IN THE- AT THAT. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD BE
UNFORTUNATELY DILLON WHERE FOR
THE NEXT- HE YEARS. BUT AND WE
HAVEN'T- IF YOU COULD BRING THAT
PHONE THAT BIGGER BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE TALKING I'VE IT I'VE SEEN
A DEVASTATE BUT SOME MY CALL
HERE. HAVE NO I WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT SO WE GET WE GET THAT
ACTION WOULD BE- I. HAVEN'T
HEARD OF I THOUGHT THAT I HAD.
UP LET TRY. TO YEAH. NO IT'S NOT
POPPING UP YET. HOLD. HELLO
SORRY THAT I'M HAVING A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. YEAH
WHAT NOW HOWEVER THERE YEAH YEAH
THE OKAY. MAYBE IT ISN'T THE
SUBWAY. OKAY LIKE. YOU SEE IT
NOW THANK YOU. SORRY ABOUT THAT
ARTICLE THAT FOR THAT THANKS FOR
LETTING KNOW. YOU CAN SEE HERE
DEVELOPING ACTUALLY IN THE- AREA
. HERE IN MONTEREY CA AND YOU
COULD SEE THAT. THIS IS A FIELD
THAT WAS PLANTED NORMALLY IN
WHAT TO BE THE OUT OF THE BETTER
WILL HARPER DID OF ACCESS COULD
NOT BE HARPER BECAUSE ALL THE-
THAT YOU SEE THAT ARE MADE THEIR
- THEY ARE ACTUALLY KEY BY IF
YOU'RE WELCOME ALL EVERY SINGLE
. PLAN THAT YOU SEE THERE DRAW
AND- IS OF IF IT WILL INFECTION
THE BILL HAS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARE. RIVAS MENTION HINDI ARE THE
THINGS IS- ACTUALLY WE YOUR- FOR
BORN SO THIS IS A- A PASS AGAIN
CAN SURVIVE IN SOIL FOR LONG OF
. IN ON THE RIGHT FROM IS ABLE
TO IN FACT THE PLAN. AND COVERED
A BAY. CHARACTERISTIC DAMAGE TO
THEIR- YOU KNOW THAT LIKE- MY
CALL RICHARD SMITH MANY BEFORE
WE HAVE NOT SEEN IT BEFORE
BECAUSE IT IS VERY UNIQUE OF- IF. YOU GET IT- EVEN THOUGH THAT
FEARS IF NOW. A MAJOR PROBLEM
IT'S GOING AN EMERGENCY IF THAT
IF COULD NOT I NEED TO THE STATE
OF. BEEN DECEIVED WORLDWIDE ONCE
. DESCRIBES IN TYLER. IN THE-
ABOUT THE- IN NINETY NINE FIVE.
AND THEN WAS- DISCOVER IN
MONTEREY COUNTY YEARS LATER IN
ELEVEN- BUT UP UNTIL NOW FROM
TWO ELEVEN UP UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THAT IS THERE'S MORE
PRESIDENT INNOVATIVE ALL
CONSIDER A SECONDARY FIFTEEN.
YOU IT WOULD BE ALL OTHER PATENT
INFECTING PLAN THERE WERE OTHER
PATH CAL YIELD. IN HE WOULD PAID
HIM THERE KIND OF LIKE AT THE
TOP OF OR- HAS BEEN. THEIR ROOTS
NOT BEING THE MAIN HI OF THAT
OUT THERE PLAN ANYTHING YOUR
LIFE WITH- IN THE IS A PICTURE
GET SEEN. HOW EFFECT BE ON THE
LINE. A ROTTED PLAN ALL THAT
BROCK BLACK COLOR. THAT IS NOT.
WHAT BLADDER. SHOULD LOOKING
THEY SHOULD WHY AND A LOCAL NEXT
- THE PICTURE THAT YOU MENTIONED
RIGHT- BUT SO DO BAR DID THAT.
WITH IS BECAUSE THE PIECE OF ACT
DE SO PLAN DOES. NOT LONG ROOTS
BACK. OFTEN TO EIGHT. IT'S MORE
. AN ISSUE YOU COULD ON THE ON
RIGHT. THAT YOU WOULD ON.
PARTICULARS END OF THE AT THE OF
THE PEEL WHERE WERE WHETHER.
MORE ANY SOME FEEL BETTER AFTER
. AS WE SEEING AND MORE AND MORE
IN FUTURE THOUSAND TO START INTO
THE ELEVEN. EIGHTEEN THEN AGAIN
IN TWO NINETY DOT AT THE TIME
WHEN I AM. IN COUNTY IN IOWA
PRESENTED THE ISSUE A WOODEN WE
KNEW. YOU CAN. RIGHT BACK. GOT
IS WHAT WATER THE FROM ABOUT
TWENTY- BUT WHAT WE STARTED
TWENTY. AT EPIDEMIC THE WHAT THE
AND OUR- ANY FAVORITE IN FROM OF
THOSE EXAMPLE. TEXTBOOK FOLLOW
X. COMPANY OUTBREAK OF THE
DISEASE- CONCENTRATING A PARTY
AREA ACTUALLY- FROM THE ORIGINAL
SOARED OF WHERE THAT IS USED.
FOR POWER IT IS. THROUGHOUT THE
- ENTIRE. VALLEY. AND IT
COGNITIVE LOSS OF THAT IN SOME.
OF A BIRD COULD NOT HARVEST AND
- FRONT PARTICULAR FEEL LIKE YOU
COULD SEE THIS- DO THAT AGAIN
OUR- OUR FEELS THAT WAY AND HARD
BECAUSE PLANS FOR THAT NOW. EVEN
NOT THEIR REMAINING- OF THE
OPERA HARBOR- TAKEN CARE HAPPEN
HAPPENING. TO HELP YOU THEY HAD
A ECONOMIC AND- WITH MEN OF IN
LOSSES- PENNIES NOW CONSIDER IN
. TO EVEN IF UP WAS NOT A BIG
DEAL. IF NOW CONSIDER THE MAIN
ROAD BROADER PROBLEM- UP LETTERS
GOING TO A BLUE. OF COURSE THAT
- WHAT OUT TO- INC IN A PRETTY
GOOD TO ME. AND I ONE OF MY
MICHAEL THAT- THESE YOU HAVE
ACTUALLY A FIVE. IN. A PATH IN
IN AS IT WAS POINTED OUT IN
FACTORED INTO THE SESSION IT
HAPPENED IN HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
SURVIVE IN THEIR SOULS FOR VERY
LONG TIME SO KNOWING THAT THE
PATH OF THE EITHER READY PRESS
WOULD HAVE MADE IT TO THE
BOULDER LOCATION THERE IS
PRESENT IN THE COMING LOCATION.
EVEN THAT IDEA THAT IT MIGHT NOT
BE PRESIDENT IT MIGHT NOT BE
SHOWING UP VERY DRAMATICALLY-
NOW BETTER WE COULD BE. THANK
SOME SIMILAR TO WHAT WE ARE
SERVICE. IMARI COUNTY AREA-
INDUCE OTHER REGIONS IN THE
FUTURE. HI SO DR. SO BECAUSE
THESE PATHOGENS REMAIN IN THE
SOIL- FOR YEARS AS IT'S BEEN
STATED- YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS TO
THAT PLOT OF LAND THAT YOU KNOW
ONCE VERY- HIGHLY- A PRODUCTIVE.
PLOT OF LAND WHAT HAPPENS TO
THAT NEXT YEAR AND BEYOND. IS IT
JUST STAY IDLE. THAT THAT IS AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND WE ARE
TRYING TO WORK ON. APART
UNDERSTANDING MORE THOSE
PATTERNS SO ONE OF THE WHAT DID
HAPPEN IS OPPORTUNITIES MICROBES
PRODUCE THESE ARE- IT'S AN
ALMIGHTY PATHOGEN IT'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT HAPPENED IN IN THAT IS
NOT A TRIVIAL AMOUNT OF BERMAN
OUR THE TRIVIAL DATA. BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO THINK IN MIND THAT
NOT ALL THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THEIR LABEL HAS HARMED
EFFECTIVE WOULD BE ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THIS
PARTICULAR PATENT THE DEFLECTOR
OF ME STRUCTURES CALLED THE
SPORES THAT ARE LONG TERM FIX
FOR THE SURVIVAL OF STRUCTURES
THAT CAN SURVIVE DESICCATION CAN
SURVIVE WINTER CONDITIONS AND
CANCER BY THE LACK. OF DEPTH
CLOSE TO BEING IN THE SOIL SO
YOU COULD EASILY HAVE TWO YEARS
OF NOT HAVING ANY LETTER IN THE
VIDEO AND THEN YOU PLANT AGAIN
AND IT HAPPENED IN THE BOARD
JUST SHOW UP AT THE CABIN WOULD
BE TRIGGER AND THAT WOULD GIVE. SIGNAL THAT THE TECHNICAL IS
BACK IN THE FIELD BUT THAT IS
WHY WE CANNOT SIMPLY RELY ON-
ASSUMING THAT BY NOT A PLANT IN
LETTERS WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
CARE OF THE ISSUE BECAUSE THE
PATH AGAIN WOULD EVENTUALLY SHOW
UP. WHENEVER THEN- THE CROP BACK
IF SAME WAY. WE HAVE TO BE VERY
STRATEGIC IN A WAY THAT WE
CONTROL THAT HAPPENED IN TWO
STRIDES REDUCE THAT INOCULUM
BUILD UP BECAUSE AS YOU SAW IN
THAT. PREVIOUS SLIDE INTO CAN-
FAILED THAT. ARE HAVING. LIKE
THIS WOULD ALSO HAVE. FOR OFTEN
HAPPENED IN THIS. SO THIS WOULD
BE SO FEEL THAT POTENTIAL. EVEN
MEDICAL OF ARE RIGHT NOW YEAR
WHAT MORE BE A GREATER RATE. OF
THE DISEASE IN- AND NEXT YEAR
BUT MAYBE MIGHT NOT BE NEXT
BECAUSE WHETHER. ARE NOT
CONDUCIVE TWENTY COULD BE THE
FOLLOWING SO WE CANNOT JUST
SIMPLY RELIED ON THE FACT THAT
WE ONE YEAR WITH THE DISEASE AND
THE OTHER NOT. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TO BE PROACTIVE IN WAYS TO
REDUCE THAT INOCULUM BUILD UP
BECAUSE THAT IS ULTIMATELY. THAT
BUT THE WAY THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE ANY THINGS WHEN
THEY'RE ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE AFFECT THAT
EFFECTIVE YOU CAN EXPECT. IS SET
ASIDE THE TIME THAT YOU SEE THAT
SYMPTOMS YOU CAN SEE HERE ON THE
LEFT. IT'S HARD TO BELOW GROUND
SYMPTOMS- YOU CAN SEE THE ROOTS.
ARE COMPLETELY- THE PRODUCT IS
VERY GOOD WITH THAT OUR DATA AND
AS YOU MIGHT YOU WOULD SEE ON
THE PICTURE ON THE VERY LEFT-
CORNER AT THE BOTTOM- THAT RODDY
IS CONCENTRATED OUTSIDE. OF
THEIR ROUTE AND THAT IS- WATER
BODIES VERY PARTICULAR UP THESE-
YOU SEE THE DOG NOT INFECTED THE
CROWN FOR THE INTERNAL. ISSUES
OF THE ROUTE AND THAT'S WHY THE
PLANTS DON'T DIE IMMEDIATELY SO
YOU WOULD SEE ON THE PICTURE OUR
WEATHER WITHIN THE BELOW GROUND
SECTION- THE PLAN FOR THE ROOTS
ARE COMPLETELY NEW PRODUCT IN IN
MEANS TO MANY OTHER THE ROUTE.
BUT THE PASS SOME OF THE LEAST
REMAIN VERY GREEN AND ACTUALLY
LOOKS JUST FINE SMALLER BETTER
FIND IN THAT IS ONE ACTUALLY ONE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE WOULD BE
IF THAT BY THE TIME THAT. THEY
THINK THAT ARE SHOWING UP IT'S
ALREADY TOO LATE AND THERE'S
NOTHING WE CAN DO TO REVERSE.
THE EFFECTS OF THE DISEASE SO WE
HAVE TO BE PROACTIVE IN MAKING
ME- PREVENTING THAT THIS IS TO
OCCUR BY BY THE TIME THAT IT.
SHOW UP IT'S A FAMILIAR AT THE
CAN SEE ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE
OF IMAGE. THE RIGHT- THE IMAGE
THE RIGHT. OF YOUR SCREEN- YEAH
- YOU WOULD BE THAT THE RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT THERE IS A BIT A
LARGE PLAN BASICALLY HELLO PLAN
. IN YOU COULD SEE THE ATTACK OF
THE DISEASE AFFECTED. TOWARDS
LEFT IN WE DO THE SIZE OF THE-
THAT THE- IN DOT IF THE PROBE.
OF PROBABILITY IN HOW- THAT
SEEMS TO OF THE ROUTE HOW
OCCURRED. ALL THEY MORE THE PLAN
IS DEFEAT. THE LONGER KIND OF
THING FIELD WITH DOES NOT
FUNCTION ROUTE. THEY MORE THE
PLAN WOULD START SPRING CAMP. IN
THE WAY THAT THE KIND WOULD TRY
TO GET. SOME OF THE LEAST WHAT
IF THERE WORLD IN OUT. THERE ONE
OF THE MAIN TELLING GIVE UP YOU
WOULD SEE. IN THE- THE FLAG
EFFECTIVE SYMPTOMS. REMAINED
RESEMBLE WATER STRESS PLAN. FOR
YOUR RECORDS WOULD OFTEN
MISTAKEN. THEY SENTENCED BY THE
PLANTS NEED MORE WATER AND HOW
DID WAS VERY ACCURATELY-
MENTIONED. BY YOU IN IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION COMMENT THESE ARE
THE HAPPENED IN PRETTY TO. THE
SPORTS SWIMMING AND SPORTS. THIS
IS KIND OF LIKE A PERFECT STORM
SITUATION BECAUSE THE PLANTS
LOOK LIKE NEED WATER. GROWERS
PUT MORE WATER IN THEM DAYS
SPREAD THEIR SPORES. DESERVE
SWIMMING SPORT ARE SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE FEEL IN BATH WHEN
YOU SEE AN OVERALL COVERAGE OF
THE FIELD LIKE YOU SAW IN THE
PREVIOUS LIFE. EXACTLY HERE
YEAH- ONE. OF WHAT YOU WERE LIKE
TO WOULD IN THE- ON THE LEFT YOU
SEE IF THERE ARE. SOME HEALTHY
FOR SOME DRAMATIC. THAT DOT AND
WE LOOK MORE CLOSELY. AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT OF THE- THERE WITH
FROM. RE AND IN THERE ARE NO.
LONGER ROUTES WERE. WHAT THE
USES TO UP SO WATER NORTH THAT
THE IS WHY. THE PLAN FOR- YOU
CAN CLICK. AND OF THE OF YOUR
SEE AT HAD FIFTY FOUR AND WITHIN
COURTS. I'LL BE WORK IMAGES
THERE WERE TAKEN UNDER SAME SPOT
EVERY THREE WEEK SO YOU GET THE
LEFT. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY NOW-
FIVE WEEKS AFTER. WE ARE THEIR-
PLAN THAT LOOKS HERE. THANK
WATER. IT DOES LOOK LIKE THE
PLANET WHY MAYBE. THE ONE TO GET
IN WATER OUT WE PRO. THREE WEEKS
LATER. MMHM ARE THE PLAN THAT WE
HAVE SIR. DAN THREE WERE LATER
SAW THE- IN WITH MORE. IN THE
AREA NOW IT'S SHOWING THE SAME
TO. AND THEN THREE WEEKS BY
ELEVEN WEEKS AFTER PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN YOU SEE THAT THERE
MORTARBOARD THERE WERE MANY MORE
PLANTS ALREADY SHOWING THE
SYMPTOMS. ONE MORE AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY SOME PLANS THAT WERE
ALREADY COMPLETELY GONE-
PRESUMABLY. THE PLANS THAT WERE
INFECTED FIRST BECAUSE THE
SECOND I'VE I'VE HAD SITUATION
WHEN PLAN THAT. EFFECTIVE PLANT.
THE FULL CLOSER TO BE NOTHING
IMPORTANT- NEWER PLANTS SO IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THROUGHOUT
THE SEASON WE COULD SEE CONTINUE
- INFECTION SHOWING UP
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE RIGHT.
ENVIRONMENTAL. CONDITIONS ARE
PRESENT. SO NEXT. TO WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO- COMPANIES IN WE'VE
BEEN. ON THE- MARKKANEN'S VERY
ACCURATE. WITH COMING UP WITH
PRIOR OF- FOR MANAGING DISEASE
BUT IT HAS BEEN BASED ON THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE FUNDING
CAPACITY IN THE FUNDING
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
GIVEN UP UNTIL NOW. WE HAVE ONLY
BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
I'M VERY- SHORT TERM- WAY IF WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EVERY YEAR TRY
DIFFERENT NEW THINK BASED ON THE
CONDITIONS THAT ARE SHOWING.
YEAH EVERY YEAR STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE WERE OBSOLETE
VISIONARY AND I WE WERE AHEAD OF
THE ISSUE AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD ALWAYS. BE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH- LET CALIFORNIA LEAFY
GREENS RESEARCH PROGRAM THAT
STATE FUNDED THAT RESEARCH
COMPETITION WILL BE FOR THE
OUTBREAK HAPPENED SO IT ALLOWED
US TO ACTUALLY HAVE A PROJECT
ON. ONGOING PROJECTS BEFORE THEY
AND THEIR THEIR WARDS PART OF
THE OUTBREAK I HAPPEN TO EITHER
THEY EACH OF THE INTAKE. OF
COMPLETELY BY SURPRISE. EVEN
THOUGH IT TOOK WITH OUR HANDS
AND FEET HI GOOD YOU KNOW HOW TO
MANAGE IT- BUT LAST YEAR WITH
OTHER EASTERN A WEEK. WAS THE
LACK. OF THE TV SHOW UP MORTON-
LATE IN THE BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGES IN THE WEATHER
CONDITIONS WE WERE LIMITED IN A
WAY THAT HOW HOW TO PROVIDE-
MANAGEMENT ALTERNATIVE TO COURTS
TO WIN THIS NEW SOURCE OF
FUNDING. WHAT WE ARE- ARE HOPING
TO ADDRESS THESE COMPLEMENT SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE FROM
THE STANDPOINT. OF NOT JUST
PROMOTING THE USE FOR MORE
CHEMICAL APPLICATIONS WE ARE NOT
PROMOTING OR ADVERTISING THE USE
OF SOLAR FUMIGANTS BUT INSTEAD
WE ARE TRYING TO COME UP. WITH
AN INTEGRATED MANAGEMENT
APPROACH. OR WE COULD HAVE ARE
TO A- OUR INTER INTO THE EVENING
. AND FINNERTY'S OF DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES. INCLUDING CLICK-
YEAH LOOKING AT WHAT IS THE
EFFECT OF IRRIGATION LIKE I
MENTIONED THE WATER PLAYS A ROLE
IN THE DISTRIBUTION ND ALSO THE
BIOLOGY OF THIS FACTORED INTO
HOW WE CAN MANAGE THE WATER
MORE- IT'S RIDICULOUS YOU KNOW
WITH THAT WE ARE GIVEN DIFFERENT
ACROSS THE WATER THAT THEY NEED
TO BUT WE'RE NOT GIVEN EXTRA
WATER. THAT MAKES IT EASY EVEN
AWARD- PROPER PATIENT IN A WAY
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IF WE TAKE THE
LEAD TO WAY FOR S. SEASON FOUR
TO SEASON AND THEN WE PUT IT
BACK AGAIN WHAT COULD BE HOW CAN
WE FIND THIS PROBLEM WITH
PATIENT THAT WOULD REDUCE THAT
HAPPENED IN. INOCULUM BUILD UP
IN THE STORE OR PROVIDED TIME
THAT WE PUT THAT UP AGAIN WE ARE
NOT A PLAN GENE THE LETTER IN A
FIELD COMPLETELY INFECTED WITH
THE PATHOGEN. AND WE'RE LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY AT WHAT IS THE
EFFECT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS WE KNOW THAT THIS
HAPPENED IN BENEFITS FRAUD
WARMER SOILS ANYTHING YOU COULD
IMAGINE THAT- IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ANY EXCLUSIVELY LAST
YEAR WE OBSERVE WITH THE YEARS.
OF THE WEATHER CONDITIONS WERE-
WARMER IF SOLD WORK ALSO
ARMENIAN DOT L. TO ACCELERATE
THEIR BIOLOGICAL CYCLE UP TO
PASS AGAINST- IN THIS SORT OF
THE WE'RE LOOKING CLOSELY AT
THAT BUT ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT IT
MIGHT BE SOME HOPE OF A RECEIPT
SENT. OUT SIGNATURE THAT WE
MIGHT BE AND WHETHER WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE COST PLANTS ARE
CULTIVATED THAT ARE NOT.
AFFECTED AT ALL OF THE INDUCTEES
BACK CIRCLE ON THE TOP RIGHT
CORNER DID YOU WOULD BE YOU HAVE
TO IN THE SAME FIELD TO VARIETY
IS ON THE LEFT ONE THAT SEEMS TO
BE NOT AFFECTED IN ONE ON THE
RIGHT ONE THAT I. WHAT
COMPLETELY DEVASTATED- AND TAKEN
DOWN BY THE DEFEATS ABOUT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GAIN A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
WATER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD
BE USING NOT ONLY COMMERCIALLY
BUT ALSO BE USING. FOR BREEDING
BOB PROGRAM. NEXT BETTER AFTER
SAME TIME. THE OLD. WAY TO-
TESTING MORE EFFECTIVE AND- WAYS
ABUSE IN. AND WE ARE NOT.
TELLING THE INDUSTRY THAT THE
SHOULD. USE PETRIFIED BECAUSE
THE SAID WE- ON PORTER- IN LAW.
WE STILL HAVE SOME CAMERA. THAT
ARE DEFECT I CAN THIS- THIS. IN
A WHAT WE TO MAKE IF WE ARE
USING. THEIR CHEMISTRY OUT THERE
RIGHT. IN WITH THEIR-
PUBLICATION CAN. OBTAINED TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF WE ARE PUTTING
. PRACTICE THAT THEY ARE BEING
EFFECTIVE IN CONTROLLING THE
DISEASE AND NOT JUST. WASTING
NOT ONLY MONEY BUT ALSO
CONTAMINATING DISORDER WITH WITH
THE CHEMISTRY. AND ALSO
COMPLEMENT THEM ALL THESE
TECHNIQUES TO AVOID. BIOLOGICAL
CONTROL IN A WAY THAT HOW WE CAN
MAXIMIZE THEIR TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THE BENEFITS OF THAT MICROBES
EVA. MIKE GOOD MICROBES IN THE
SOIL CAN GIVE US TO OFFSET. THE
EFFECT OF THE NEGATIVE PATHOGENS
IN THE SOIL. THE WE'RE ALL
COMMENDED FROM ODEON. PLAN
HELPED TRYING TO KEEP THE PLANTS
MORE HEALTHY BUT ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME TRYING TO KEEP THE
SOIL HEALTHY WOULD LET. LET
APPLICANT BUT ALSO WITH MORE-
HEALTHY CONDITIONS THAT CAN
SUPPORT. ACTED CONTINUOUSLY TOOK
ABOUT PLANTS THAT ARE ALSO
PERFORMING BETTER INSULTING
MEDLEY DOT COMBINATIONS
PROMOTING MORE SUSTAINABLE CROP
PRODUCTION. NEXT WE ARE THEY
WHAT IS THAT WE ARE DEVELOPING
ALL OUR- RESURGENCE RODRIGUEZ IS
BY MAKING SURE THAT ALL THE
DISCOVERED ALL THE FINDINGS THAT
WE HAVE. WE ARE HELPING THEM IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE INDUSTRY
WE ARE CUTTING OUT. ALL ALONG
TRIAL- SET THE TRIAL WAITED
GROWERS IN COMMERCIAL FIELD BUT
ALSO IN RESEARCH- IF THEY HAVE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO NOT A-
CHEAP ALL WHOLEHEARTEDLY
PARTICIPATE YOU FORMATION THE
NOTED. THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY BY I
KNOW BUT WE ARE IN. DELIVER THAT
IN. TO IN THE- THROUGH THE FOUR
EVERY WEEK WE GIVE OUR- TO THE-
OR WHAT WE BEEN TED WATER ARE.
IN WHAT IS WORK AND WHAT IS THE
STOCK AND WITH THAT- I WOULDN'T
LET. BE I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
IN IN IN IN. MENTION MAYBE
PERHAPS AND ECONOMY POSITIVE
NOTE EVEN THOUGH BY THE DEVIL.
AND HAPPIEST EFFECT OF THE-
DISEASE HAVE HAD A IN THE- I
ALSO TO MENTION THAT PUBLIC.
THAT HAVE TO BE. THROUGH THE
RECENT WE DO. ANY IS THERE COULD
OF WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT IN.
VALLEY WE HAVE- I MIGHT AT B. I.
LI AYE PART I RECALLED FROM OF
MAKE. AND WE BEEN WORK UNTIL
VERY ACTIVELY WITH US FROM THE
COMMUNITIES. FOR MY ARM
SUFFICIENT BUT ALSO FRONT-
HOLDER EVEN UNIVERSE. ENGAGE
THEM INTO TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION GETTING THEM INFORMED
ABOUT A WATER IN CHALLENGES IN
NEED- DIFFERENT DISEASES HAVE
BECOME OR CONTENT OF OUR FORTY
FIFTH IN A WAY THAT IS STUDENTS
ARE TRYING. TO COME UP WINNERS
OF PROBLEM SOLVING SOLUTIONS
FOUR DAYS- FORTY FIFTY FIFTY- WE
CAN GET THERE DEFINITELY THE
FUNDING FROM THE S. B. ONE SEVEN
IT WHAT ALLOW TO KEEP SUPPORTING
LOCAL STUDENTS TO ENGAGE IN
THESE. RESEARCH OPPORTUNITIES
AND ALSO GAIN KEEPING. IF THE
BALLOT BEING THAT COMMITMENT IN
THAT ENGAGEMENT WITH THEIR
INDUSTRY TO TRY TO SOLVE. THEIR
CHALLENGES AND NEEDS THAT
BETWEEN THE THREE HAVE- IN
ADDITION. WE SEE THIS ARE THE
TWO WAYS- APPROACH IN A SENSE
THAT WE ARE NOT ONLY TRAINING
HARD IN THIS REGARD FOR OUR
WORKFORCE WE'RE ALSO. AND IN A
WAY TO ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
LABOR SHORTAGES THAT WE HAVE IN
THE NEEDS THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS
FOR MORE TECHNICALLY TRAINED- I
WORK FOR IS THAT CURRENTLY IS
NEEDED. IN IN AN INDUSTRY BUT
ALSO WE'RE GIVEN EXPANDING. THE
WAY THAT WE SHARED THIS
INFORMATION NOT ONLY IN THE
CLASSROOM BUT ALSO WITH FARM
WORKERS AND PEOPLE IN THE
INDUSTRY ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT ARE HERE TODAY
OF. ROUTINELY IN IN- SEX WHERE
WE SHARE. OUR- KNOWLEDGE. AND
RESPECT. WITH MEMBERS OF THE
INDUSTRY INTO PARMA IN THEIR
THEIR EFFECT. IN ANY INTEREST
FOR EVEN IN ONLY DO FULL WHAT ON
THE TECH ROLE. AT THE FAR. BUT
ALSO TRAIN SOME OF THE FAR MORE
THAT ARE. ON THE GO IN FIELD
ACCERN. SEEN THE SEASON IN A WAY
THAT THEY CAN OPEN UP THESE THE
- THEY ARE A TOWARD. THE THEY
CAN ALSO. THEIR MANAGER THEIR
PCA'S- IN A WAY THAT WE GET MORE
PROACTIVELY CAN AND IMPORTANTLY
RESPOND TODAY. THE THING THAT
HAVE SO I WANT TO THANK- ALL.
FOR THE SUPPORT THAT HAS BEEN
GIVEN. TO US FOR THE S. B. ONE
SEVENTY AND I WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT. THE RESEARCH IS
DEFINITELY NEEDED. THIS IS THE
FUNDING OF WHAT A LOT OF COULD
TAKE THEIR RESEARCH AND COME UP
WITH MORE. OF A START THE
FEATURES MORE SYSTEMATICALLY IN
A WAY THAT WE CAN LOOK. COME UP
WHEN NOT ONLY WAITED A SHORT
TERM SOLUTION BUT ACTUALLY MORE
ROBUST ALTERNATIVE THAT. WOULD
BE MORE- AT FIFTEEN EVEN IF THE
THEM TO DITCH. IN THE CLASS THAT
WE SEE FOR YEAR TO YEAR WE IDEAS
COME UP WITH ALL. THAT WOULD NOT
NECESSARY. E OVERTAKEN BY THE
POWER OR NOT BE AFFECTED BY THE
FACT THAT THE WEATHER CHANGED
FROM ONE YEAR THE OTHER ONE BUT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE
IT. IS FACTORED IN THE WAY TO
COMING UP WITH ALTERNATIVES WHAT
ALSO SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL-
STUDENTS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I APPRECIATE ALL
THE- SUPPORT THAT YOU'VE GIVEN
US. ABSOLUTELY DOCTOR REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY SO
INFORMATIVE AND- LOOK FORWARD I
WAS. YOU KNOW HOW TO BE
CONVERSATION WITH. OUR STAFF AND
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE ALL OF THE
MATERIALS THAT- YOU KNOW I HAVE
BEEN SHOWN HERE IT'S INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE TO REALLY. APPRECIATE
YOU MENTIONING THE WORK FORCE
OPPORTUNITIES WE JUST HAD A- A
PREVIOUS HEARING- THIS MORNING-
HIGHLIGHTING YOU KNOW AG TECH IN
THE FUTURE. OF AGRICULTURE AND
THE POTENTIAL RUN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOBS AND YOU KNOW AS WE SEEK
TO TRAIN THE NEXT. THE
GENERATION TO WORK- IN
AGRICULTURE SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU EMPHASIZING SOMETIME ON
THAT- AND SO WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO OUR LAST MEMBER OF THIS
PANEL OF A- OF THIS PANEL. RIGHT
NOW I'VE ALREADY FIGURED OUT HOW
TO WORK. THE AIR. I HAVE IN THE
CENTER MODE AND I'M NOT SURE HOW
THE- IT GOT OUT YOU KNOW. YEAH I
KNOW OUR TEAM BUT I HAVEN'T
LOOKED AT IT IT- IT LOOKS FINE
ON OUR END AS WELL. OKAY OKAY
GREAT PERFECT SO HEY- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR- ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT- SOME OF THE RESEARCH
AND SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'VE CONDUCTED HERE ON TRIPS
AND- IMPATIENCE NIKADA BOTTLERS
IN A RESEARCH ENTOMOLOGIST WITH
USDA AND KILLING US. I STARTED
HERE IN THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND THIS IS
BECOME REALLY A TOP PRIORITY FOR
MY RESEARCH PROGRAM TO REALLY
SUPPORT THE LEAFY GREENS
INDUSTRY HERE IN THE SALINAS
DOLLARS. DR SO REALLY BRIEFLY I
THINK A LOT OF YOU HAVE SEEN
PICTURES OF MINE AND HE JUST
GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF THE
BACKSTORY OF THE VIRUS WAS FIRST
DESCRIBED IN THE NETHERLANDS IN
THE EIGHTIES- AND IT WASN'T
REPORTED UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
SIX'S RICHARD SMITH MENTIONED IN
IN HIS PRESENTATION MONTEREY
COUNTY IN LOTUS- AND THEN FROM
TWO THOUSAND SIX IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WE SAW SOME REALLY MINOR
TO SEVERE ISOLATED OUTBREAKS IT
WASN'T REALLY UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE WE ONLY STARTED TO SING THE
RECEIVE THE RE EMERGENCE OF THIS
VIRUS. AND SEVERE OPERATIONS
THROUGHOUT MONTEREY COUNTY- AND
SOME OTHER COASTAL LETTUCE
REGIONS- AND AS MARY MENTIONED
UP TO A 100% CROP LOSSES- A BIG-
ECONOMIC IMPACT AND ONE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS TO MARK NATION ALL
JUST REITERATE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IT WAS ACTUALLY THE FIRST
REPORT OF THE DESERT LET
DISTRIBUTION REGION SO IMPERIAL
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES THAT
REPORTED- THIS VIRUS AS WELL AS
IN YOU MIND TALKING TO ARIZONA
SO THAT SUGGESTS THAT THIS VIRUS
IS SPREADING TO OTHER LETTERS
PRODUCING REGIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY I DON'T THINK IT'S
RELATED TO THE PRODUCTION HERE-
BUT THIS VIRUS WAS ALSO
DESCRIBED IN LOTUS PRODUCTION
INCREASED SO- AS A WHOLE THIS
THIS VIRUS IS BECOMING. MORE
ECONOMICALLY IMPORTANT IN LEAFY
GREENS NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
AND ARIZONA BUT OTHER REGIONS AS
WELL KILL ANYTHING THAT WE LEARN
HERE FROM THE RESEARCH CAN
DEFINITELY SHED LIGHT IN TERMS
OF MANAGEMENT. FOR OTHER REGIONS
AS WELL- I'M JUST GONNA GO
THROUGH A BUNCH PICTURES- I
THINK SEEN ON OF WOMEN THIS
POINT SO MAYBE ALREADY.
TRANSPLANT BUT THIS THE FINAL BY
. SO IMPAIR IN THE- SPOT MYERS.
THIS IS A LUNATIC IN THIS.
PICTURE RIGHT HERE REALLY THE
BROWNING ON THE LEADS STARTING
OF THE GROWTH YOU CAN SEE ON THE
RIGHT SIDE- MOTION THOSE PLANTS
ARE INFECTED THERE'S ONE THAT
LOOKS HEALTHY ON THE TOP RIGHT
CORNER- MY FEELING IS IT IS
PROBABLY IS INFECTED AS WELL.
IT'S JUST A SYMPTOMATIC SELF
ALSO BE TALKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOME PARALLELS IN HOW WE-
THINK ABOUT COVERAGE BECAUSE IT
CERTAINLY HELPED ME. UNDERSTAND
THIS VIRUS FROM- IN LETTUCES
WALLS. HOW THIS IS SAME HILDA
ARE NOW FIELD TWENTY TWENTY YOU
CAN SEE THAT THEY'RE SWEET
ALYSSUM WHICH IS A- A BENEFICIAL
PLANT- THAT'S PLANTED IN THERE
AND THAT'S REALLY TO ATTRACT.
BENEFICIAL INSECTS PREDATORY
INSECTS TO TRY TO MANAGE THE
ROPES NATURALLY- YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S- A WIDESPREAD AMOUNT OF
VIRUS INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT THIS
FIELD- THIS FIELD WAS A 100%
CROP LOSS BY THE TIME- IF CAME
TO HARVEST. SO NEXT FIVE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WHICH ALL OF THE
SAME THING IN CERTAIN AREAS-
SOME OF THOSE PLANS FOR A BIGGER
ALL THE OTHER ONES THAT ARE
STUNTED AND SMALLER- THOSE ARE
INFECTED WITH IMPATIENS NECROTIC. SPOT FIRES. NEXT AND INTO THE
NINE WE REALLY WANT SOME-
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL STUDIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE MOVEMENT OF THIS
VIRUS AND- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS QUITE SURPRISING IS-
HOW EARLY THIS VIRUS CAN BE
INTRODUCED WITHIN A FIELD AND SO
THIS IS A PRETENDING FEEL-
STAGE. OF A LETTUCE CROP AND-
THAT'S PROBABLY OUT ABOUT THREE
THREE TO FOUR WEEKS OF GROWTH
AND YOU'RE ALREADY SEEING VERY
STRONG SYMPTOMS. OF THIS VIRUS
SHOW UP ON A NEXT SLIDE. THAT
SAME FIELD WE JUST MONITOR THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE FIELD. ON THE ENTIRE
CROP CYCLE WAS ABOUT NINE WEEKS
THAT'S ABOUT AS FAST AS- YOU'LL
GO FROM PLANTING TO HARVEST- IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY IN KNOX
AROUND YOU KNOW SUMMER. LATE
SUMMER- AND THIS WAS A 100% CROP
LOSSES WELL ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT.
INTENSITY OF LETTUCE PRODUCTION
IN THIS REGION IS- IS QUITE
QUITE INTENSE AND SO IT'S NOT. A
MONO CROP THAT IS PLANTED AS
THERE'S A LOT OF LOCATIONS THAT
ARE HEAVILY RELIED ON. AND ON A
PER ACRE BASIS YOU CAN GET
MULTIPLE PLANTINGS OF WHAT IS
WITHIN THE SEASON ITSELF. JUST
BECAUSE ONE ONE SECTION IS QUICK
OUT OF THE CLEAR EARLIER ON IN
THE SEASON DOESN'T MEAN THAT
YOUR NEXT PAINTING WILL BE AND
SO THAT'S WHAT WE SAW HERE. IS
REALLY THE MOVEMENT OF THE
BUYERS THROUGHOUT THIS ONE
FIELD. BUT IT ALSO IMPACTED CHIU
NEIGHBORHOOD FIELDS THAT WERE
PLANTED RIGHT AFTER THIS.
EXCELLENT I AND THEN THIS IS
REAL OUR ARCHITECT SO MISTER.
NOT BY YOU CAN TOUCH THE VICE
YOU CAN TRANSMIT THAT IT'S NOT
ME CAN'T TRYING. THAT'S ACTUAL
FRASER IT. IS ACTUALLY
TRANSMITTED BY THE IMPACT WHICH
IS THE WATSON PARKER'S. WHICH AS
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION INTO VERY SMALL
INSECTS SO ONE U. TWO
MILLIMETERS- YEAH AND THAT'S A
VERY EARLY. A LETTUCE PLANT ON
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE AND I'VE
JUST HIGHLIGHTED HOW SMALL THESE
INSECTS ARE- IN ADDITION THEY
LEAVE A LOT OF FEEDING DAMAGE OF
THOSE ARE THAT'S DAMAGE SUCH
CALLS FROM FEEDING BY THE
INFECTED CELL. AND BRINGS UP THE
POINT THAT IN ADDITION TO JUST
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT THE VIRUS
HOUSE- THERE'S ALSO- BEATING ALL
LOSSES JUST THEIR DAMAGE
COSMETIC DAMAGE THAT'S-
INFLICTED BY THIS IMPACT IN A
LOT OF THIS CHANGES. NOT ONLY
WITHIN THE U. S. BUT IT ALSO HAS
DEPENDED ON STANDARDS SET BY THE
EXPORT MARKET WHICH IS STRONGLY
LIMITED. MATERIALS THAT ARE
GROWERS AND PCAS CAN USE- AND
THAT ULTIMATELY AFFECTS REALLY-
THE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. THAT
ARE INDUCED INDUSTRY CAN
IMPLEMENT FIVE HOURS AGAIN
DISMISSED TRACTORS JUST
HIGHLIGHTING. REALLY THE
INFESTATION THAT. CAN OCCUR AT A
VERY EARLY STAGE- VERY BRIEFLY
I'M GONNA SPEND TOO MUCH ON HERE
THE POINT IS BOB DOLE CHIU SMALL
THE FOURTEENTH CAN LIE. HUNDRED
OF DAYS THROUGHOUT HER LIFE
CYCLE AND THEY HAVE A WIDE RANGE
OF DEVELOPMENT TEMPERATURES SO
BETWEEN FORTY FIVE AND A HUNDRED
AND FOUR DEGREES- THIS INSECT
WILL CONTINUE DEVELOPING
CONTINUOUS LIFECYCLE- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE WESTERN
FLOWER THRIPS IS GOT. A LOT OF
FLOWERS AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE-
THEY'RE CALLED THE WESTERN
FLOWER THRIPS. SO ANYTHING THAT
FLOWERS A LOT NOT FALL INTO THE
HOST RANGE THE NUMBER OF PLANTS
THAT CAN SUPPORT THE WESTERN
PARTNERS IS IN THE HUNDREDS- IN
TERMS OF HOW OF IRISES SO MERRY
- THE COUSIN OF MINE IS TO. AS
TOMATOES WILT VIRUS AND THAT'S
ANOTHER VIRUS- THAT HAVEN'T
QUITE REACHED ECONOMIC LEVELS IN
LETTERS BUT- AFTER FAMILIAR WITH
TOMATO PRODUCTION IN CENTRAL
VALLEY IT'S BECOME A PROBLEM IN
THAT REGION. ON THE SAME THING
JUST LIKE FOR US WE KNOW THAT
THE HOST RANGE FOR I. S. B.
SHOWS. THE NUMBER OF PLANTS THAT
CAN BE INFECTED BY THE VIRUS IS
ALSO IN THE HUNDREDS. AND SO IF
YOU JUST THINK ABOUT A
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE ON
REDUCING. HABITAT STILL LIMITED.
VOTES THAT CAN SUPPORT EITHER
INTACT FOR THE VIRUS BECOMES
EXTREMELY. OVERWHELMING AND
SHALL- AND THEN THIS IS JUST
KIND OF FOLLOW UP TO ORDINARY
SAID ABOUT. OF IDEA TEMPERATURES
IN THIRDS POPULATIONS AND SO I
JUST PUT THEIR GENERALLY THAT
THE LETTER SEASON IN OUR REGION
RUNS. ALL THE CRIME REALLY
MONTHS ARE FROM MARCH TO
NOVEMBER AND THEN IT SWITCHES
DOWN TO IMPERIAL AND RIVERSIDE.
DURING THE WINTER TIME AND SO
THERE'S QUITE THIS INTEGRATION
BETWEEN THE TWO PRODUCING
REGIONS BUT- WE DID HAVE A
COOLER CLIMATE WITH COOLER
TEMPERATURES THIS PAST YEAR AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN SEE- FROM
THAT BLACK ONE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- AND REALLY IT'S THE WEATHER
THAT **** DISORIENTATING FASTER
DEVELOPMENT AS I MENTIONED IN A
FEW SLIDES AGO. CELL HIGH
POPULATIONS GENERALLY INCREASE
IN PROGRESS THROUGH. THE WARMER
MONTHS NEXT FIVE. I AM NOT SURE
CORE. FOR HOW WE- DEVELOPMENT
STAR. OF THE- AS WELL NEXT FIVE.
AND THEN FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SLUGS STUDY ON THE
SHOWING THAT THAT PLANTING SLOT
WAS BETWEEN JUNE AND SEPTEMBER-
AND AS I MENTIONED YOU CAN GET
MORE THAN ONE PLANTING ON A PER
ACRE BASIS AND SO. ONE THERE ARE
STILL MONTHS OUT MUNSTER GO IN
THAT SEASON AND SO ALL THE
FIELDS. AROUND THAT SUFFERED
JUSTICE HARBINGERS OF THE VIRUS-
ANYWAYS JUST TRYING TO PROVIDE
SOME PERSPECTIVE ON ON THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE ALREADY TRIED TO
DO TO UNDERSTAND THIS VIRUS AND
THE FACT- TEMPERATURES. OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS ON THIS REPORT
FROM ONE OF THE LOCATIONS- IN
SALINAS AND SO ON AVERAGE. OF
THE HIGH AIR OF THE HIGH
TEMPERATURE AND LOW TEMPERATURES
HAVE INCREASED OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS. AND JUST REFERRING
BACK TO THE DEVELOPMENTAL
THRESHOLDS FOR THRIPS DOCTRINE
THAT RED LINE AS- YOU CAN SEE
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO OVER THE
PAST. TWENTY YEARS- DOCTOR HOLD-
IS NOT REAL IS THE TEMPERATURES
ARE NOT BELOW THAT THRESHOLD AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
NEVER ACTUALLY GET. A BREAK IN
THE REPRODUCTION OF THIS INSECT.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WORSE
HISTORICALLY MAYBE POPULATIONS
WERE SUPPRESSED IN THE
WINTERTIME. WORSE NOW WILL WE
CONTINUE TO SEE ACTIVITY EVEN
WHEN NOT THIS IS NOT PRESENT IN
THE BALLOT- MANAGE CHALLENGES I
BROKE IT DOWN INTO THREE PIECES
AND I THINK I WANTED TO DO IT
THIS WAY BECAUSE I THINK IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE COMPLEXITY BEHIND
US. BUT WE TALK ABOUT THE
DIRECTION MANAGEMENT OF THREATS
ALL THESE POINTS ARE NOT- ARE
FAMILIAR TO YOU ALREADY BECAUSE
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT- BUT- HIGHLY
REPRODUCTIVE SMALL INSECTS. THIS
IDEA NGUYEN TRAVEL WE'VE DONE
SOME STUDIES WERE REDUCING
TARIFFS TWENTY FIVE FEET HIGH IN
THE WIN COLUMN SO IF YOU THINK
ABOUT TRYING TO PT IT VERY
ORDER SUPPRESSING POPULATION.
I'M COMING INTO A FIELD THAT
BECOMES INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT IF
THEY'RE MOVING THAT HIGH UP IN
THE WIN COLUMN. AS MARK
MENTIONED VERY LIMITED CHEMICAL
OPTIONS- AND ALL OF THIS AFFECTS
NOT ONLY WHAT'S AVAILABLE BUT
ALSO THIS IDEA OF RESISTANCE
MANAGEMENT. AND THEN THE LARGE
HOST RANGE WE TALK ABOUT THE
VIRUS NEXT SLIDE- THERE ARE NO
DIRECT METHOD FOR PREVENTING OR
TREATING THE VIRUS SO IF WE
THINK ABOUT PROVISIONS. BAXEEN
SOCIAL DISTANCING MASKING YOU
CAN'T DO THAT FOR PLANTS RIGHT
AND SO. HOW DO WE MANAGE THE
VIRUS- AND CREATING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO DO THIS- WE WERE
ALSO NOT AT THE POINT WHERE YOU
SEE A LOT OF GENETIC RESISTANCE
IN BY THIS VARIETIES AND SELF
JENNIFER MENTIONED IN HER SLIDE.
ON A LOT OF THE EFFORTS ARE
GOING INTO BREEDING WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS A LONG TERM.
STRATEGY FOR MANAGING THE VIRUS
BY GENERATING GENETIC RESISTANCE
BUT THAT'S JUST NOT AVAILABLE
WIDELY TO THE INDUSTRY AT THIS
POINT- AND AGAIN THE LAST PART
IS DOES THE HOST RANGE- IDEA FOR
THIS VIRUS SO. NEXT SLIDE AND
THEN. FINALLY THINKING ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM AS A WHOLE SO WHEN
YOU BRING TRIPS AND I NEED TO BE
TOGETHER I WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT TRANSMISSION OCCURS WITHIN
MINUTES OF FEEDING ALLOWED US.
CONSERVE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE INHERENT
DESPERATE THIS IDEA OF MOVEMENT
IF YOU TALK ABOUT THE LIMITED
CHEMICAL OPTIONS PRIMARILY.
THOSE THAT ARE CONTACT
COMMISSION DREES. IF YOU YES ALL
YOU HAVE ARE CHEMISTRY AND CAN
TAKE SOME MINUTES HOW DO YOU GET
OF THIS THING AND IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT TO DO THAT SO NEXT
LINE AND ON TOP OF THAT- JUST TO
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH HERE OF
COMPLEXITY IS THIS IDEA OF
CALLING FACTIONS WITH AT THE END%
WILL NOT. SLIDE SAME THING
YOU'RE SAYING YOU SEEN THE
SLIDE- OR EXAMPLES OF THIS
BUDGET CAN I AND RICHARD WE
TESTED. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
PLANS MAYBE TEN PLANTS OUT OF
THIS FIELD RANDOMLY PICKED. FROM
THIS CORNER AND EACH ONE OF THEM
HAD BOTH MINUS THE ENTIRE TEAM
WILL. AND I THINK WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT HERE IS
THAT. WE REALLY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THESE TWO PATHOGENS AND
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IF WE CAN UNDERSTAND. IF ONE
PATHOGEN IS MAKING THE PLANT
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO INFECTION BY
THE OTHER THAN THAT MIGHT GUIDE
US IN TERMS OF MANAGING ONE
PASSED THE CHEN VERSUS THE
OTHER- AS AN ENTIRE SYSTEM SO
NEXT SLIDE- AND THEN FINALLY I
AM FIVE. STRIPPED EVERYTHING
AWAY AND JUST LAST RESEARCH
PROGRESS AND OPPORTUNITIES AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND WHERE SOME
OF THE S. B. ONE SEVENTY FUNDS
ARE GONNA BE USED TO ADDRESS.
NOT ONLY THE INDIVIDUAL
COMPONENTS BUT THE ENTIRE THING
IS A HOLD ON THE NEXT SLIDE. SO
FOR THRIPS- THIS IS SOME WORK
THAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING A LOT
OF IT IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEAFY GREENS. PROGRAM
AND WE'VE BEEN REALLY GRATEFUL
TO HAVE VERY GOOD SUPPORT FROM
THEM SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WHEN I STARTED SO. WE'RE
UTILIZING PREDATORY INSECTS TO
COMBAT BURKE CHAU RELEASING WHAT
WE CALLED BENEFICIAL INSECTS
WERE WORKING WITH THE COMPANY
DOING DRUM RELEASES AND- SOME
ORGANIC PRODUCTION. OUR
MONITORING POPULATIONS WERE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND MOVEMENTS
AND BEHAVIOR- WE'RE TRYING TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME-
HAZARDS THAT ARE BEING USED AND
IF WE CAN MAXIMIZE THAT- USING
SOME OF THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AS YOU SEE THERE ON THE RIGHT
PROCEDURE INSPIRATION- MARC
MIGHT BE ABLE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED BUT THE ESTIMATE IS
THAT YOU COULD REDUCE IT DOWN TO
ONE TENTH OF ALL IN. AT THE
EARLIEST APPLICATION PHASE WHICH
I THINK IS JUST SUPER EXCITING.
WE TALK ABOUT I. S. B. NEXT
SLIDE- WEED ABATEMENTS ON MARION
RICHARD IF TALK BOTH AOUT THIS.
QUITE EXTENSIVELY BUT A LOT OF
THE RESEARCH. THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO CONDUCT HAS GUIDED A LOT
OF THE STATE AND PRO- TO NAY.
SOME OF THE- FOR THE FIRE- AND
THEN. TO PLAY IMMUNE HIGH FIRES
AND SO THE J. POINT BUILD A
HEALTHY PLAN. A STRONG GROUP-
CAN POTENTIAL HELP FIGHT OFF
SOME OF THOSE- SLIDE- WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT IMPROVING.
PROGRAMS TO MONITOR. DOCTORING
SO IDENTIFYING POPULATIONS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE THE PLAYERS. AND
THEN- REALLY LOOKING AT THE
INTERACTIONS AS I ALLUDED TO IN
THE PREVIOUS. LIFE AND THEN THE
LAST THING- IS REALLY NOVEL AND
EMERGING BIOTECHNOLOGIES WRITTEN
SECOND HE'S MANAGEMENT SO AREN'T
ANY INTERFERENCE WAS ONE OF THE
PROJECTS THAT YOU SAW IN
JENNIFER'S PRESENTATION THERE'S
A NUMBER OF OTHER PROJECTS THAT
I'M WORKING ON. WITH USDA TO TRY
TO BUILD ON THESE NEW TOOLS FOR
US TWO YEARS AS WE CONTINUE TO.
MOVE FORWARD AND GO THROUGH
DIFFERENT REGULATORY PROCESSES-
TO ACCEPT A LOT OF THESE-
STRATEGIES AS WELL AS INTEGRATE
THEM INTO MODELS SO. NEXT FIVE
AND THEN WHAT I'VE DONE HERE IS
JUST HIGHLIGHTED. A FEW OF THESE
IN READ THAT STAND OUT IN MY
MIND FOR HOW- THIS FUNDING WILL
BE USED AND I THINK THESE ARE
ADDRESSING. THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING
ADDRESSED HERE- BUT BUT THE
BIGGER QUESTION ABOUT HOW THIS
FUNDING MIGHT BE USED THIS IS
HOW I'M SORT OF ENVISIONING IT.
CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
PROJECTS THAT WE CAN PURSUE AS
WELL. SO NEXT SLIDE. THIS IS
JUST KIND OF A PER. SLIDES WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT SO I MENTIONED
COMMUTERS FATHER WILL VIRUS INTO
METAL PROCESSING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
IPM STRATEGY THAT THEY'VE
DEVELOPED- TO REALLY GET THIS
OUT TO THE INDUSTRY AND THEY HAD
AN EXCELLENT RESEARCH TEAM- TO
PLANT PATHOLOGIST CHU
ENTOMOLOGIST AND FIVE EXTENSION
PERSONNEL. WORKING ON THIS- WHEN
THE DISEASE REALLY STARTED
SHOWING UP IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
RESEARCH BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THIS PAPER WAS PUBLISHED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND WHAT I'M
REALLY JUST TRYING TO GET OUT AS
YOU KNOW RESEARCH CAN BE A LONG
TERM THING. YOU KNOW BUT WE HAVE
TO STRATEGIZE WHAT IS A SHORT
TERM GOAL AND A LONG TERM GOAL-
AND IN THIS EXAMPLE IT WAS
QUITE- QUITE A LONG TIME BEFORE
THEY WERE ABLE TO REALLY. BUILD
SOMETHING THAT WAS ROBUST AND
ADOPTABLE. BY THE INDUSTRY. HI
SO WHY CAN'T WE USE SAME IN PART
OF THE PARTY THE REALLY THE BIG
REASON IS BECAUSE- THE CULTURE
OF AGRICULTURE WITHIN OUR REGION
AND SO OF THE SPECIALTY CROP
INDUSTRY HERE IS VERY STRONG
IT'S VERY DIVERSE AND VERY
DYNAMIC AND SO I MENTION THIS
IDEA OF CROP ROTATIONS- REALLY
TO- TO- WITH LEAF BLOWERS AND
HAD LESS BEING REALLY SOME OF
OUR BIGGEST- CROPS WITHIN OUR
REGION YOU LOOK AT THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT'S COMING OUT
OF MONTEREY COUNTY IT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT TO SECURE-
BOTH THE STABILITY OF BEING ABLE
TO PRODUCE THESE CROPS TO
STAYING UP LATE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE. FIVE JUST
REALLY MY LAST FLIGHT HERE JUST
LOOKING AT IBM FROM A HOLISTIC.
STANDPOINT AND SO THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT- I THINK ABOUT THAT
I THINK JP AND EVERYONE ELSE IN
THIS ROOM BEHIND ME THINKS
ABOUT. AS OUT WERE NOT JUST
CENTERED IN THAT GREEN CIRCLE
WITHIN THE MIDDLE THERE THAT
SAYS TAX MANAGEMENT. BUT WERE
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THESE OTHER
PARTS TO REALLY DEVELOP
SOMETHING THAT IS. ACCEPTABLE
SOCIALLY ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY. AND THE TOOLBOX
FOR MANAGING NOT ONLY HONEST BE.
TESTING AS WELL AS GOING TO HAVE
TO BE VERY DIVERSE AND VERY
ROBUST AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO I
THINK THAT MY LOS- YOU AFTER THE
QUESTION WE ARE RECEIVING
FUNDING FROM MY HOME AGENCY U.
S. D- BUT GREAT SUPPORT FROM A
LOT OF OTHER AGENCIES- AS WELL
AND THEN A LOT OF COLLABORATORS
THAT WE DROPPED INTO SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS TO SUPPORT THIS
RESEARCH SO. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. WELL THANK YOU
DANIEL I REALLY APPRECIATE WE'RE
UP AGAINST TIME AND- GOING TO
GET- WE HAVE TO BE OUT OF THIS
ROOM HERE MOMENTARILY BUT I
REALLY WANT TO THINK- YOU KNOW
ALL THE PANELISTS TO WANNA THINK
THE WORK. THAT HAS BEEN DONE ONE
THING THE GOAL SHIPPER
ASSOCIATION IN MARIN COUNTY FARM
BUREAU ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE HAS BEEN- INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- AND YOU KNOW AS WAS
MENTIONED BY MARK THAT WE HAVE A
DISASTER ON OUR HANDS AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY WHAT WE HAVE YES THIS
IS A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE- IT YOU
KNOW HAPPY THAT- YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
BY- YOU KNOW THE- STATE BUDGET-
FROM- THIS CURRENT YEAR- HOPE
THAT THAT WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BUT BUT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THIS IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM THIS IS A THREAT
TO- THE PRODUCTION YOU KNOW A
VERY SUCCESSFUL. SO PRODUCTION
IN THE SALINAS VALLEY I IT'S A
THREAT TO YOU KNOW THE JOBS THAT
THE INDUSTRY HAS HISTORICALLY-
PRODUCED THERE IN- THE SALINAS
VALLEY. AND SO CERTAINLY AS A
STATE WE NEED TO TAKE A VERY- A
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO A PARTNER.
WITH THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
ALREADY. TO SEE HOW WE CAN
OVERCOME MANY OF THESE
CHALLENGES BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL FOR MAKING THE TIME THANK
YOU FOR. THE INFORMATION AND AS
ALWAYS LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU-
AND WITH THAT- VICTOR DO WE-
HAVE LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL OPEN UP- THIS. ROOM FOR
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE WHO WISH
TO MAKE COMMENTS. SEE NON- WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES ARE
THERE- SOME PHONE LINES OPEN. IF
YOU LIE TO- TAKE A COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU HAVE A COMMENT COMING
IN ONE MOMENT.
ON WHY. YEAH WE
GO TO LINES SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DAN GLEASON
CAMPUS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY.
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR PULLING
TOGETHER THIS VERY FRIGHTENING
AND VERY IMPORTANT- HEARING I'M
SURE WE'LL BE HEARING MORE ABOUT
IT I JUST WANT TO OFFER OUR
SERVICES IF YOU HAVE THAT
CALIFORNIANS COULD YOU PROVIDE A
PERSON WHO WERE WORKING
SCIENTISTS TO- TO DNA BARCODE
FUND G. INSECTS AND PATHOGENS
STATEWIDE. AND AND THE TO
ADVANCE REALLY SOME REALLY HIGH
TECH DETECTION TECHNIQUES THAT
ARE- USING META BARCODING AND
I'M SURE MANY OF THE SPEAKERS
TODAY- ARE AWARE OF THAT
ADVANCED STUFF AND I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN DEVELOP THESE TOOLS
AND THAT'S ENOUGH TO TRYING TO
BE AN INSISTENCE ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF IT- THAT TODAY HAD A REALLY
GOOD HEARING ON. BUILDING TAX
TRAINING TRACK- FOR THE
AGRICULTURE I'M SORRY MISSTATING
IT BUT ESSENTIALLY- TRAINING-
YOUNG FARMERS IN ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES- TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
DIRECTLY LIKE THIS AND I DO HOPE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AND
BILL- I WILL BE ABLE TO PUT
THEIR HEADS TOGETHER AND FIND A
WAY TO GET CSU AND OTHERS
INVOLVED. IN SOME SOLUTIONS HERE
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR COMMENTS.
OPERATOR THERE ANY OTHER CALLS
THE QUEUE. AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. FANTASTIC AND
WITH THAT WE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED.